e
e yeah can you is it full screen I'm
sorry
for
e
um thank you all for being here I know
it's early on Friday after a long
session day yesterday um but uh we have
uh Steve Petty Steven Petty here um he
is uh come to talk to us about some of
the covid
protocols uh and I cannot even begin to
introduce him and do him justice so I
will just let him if you don't mind
introduce yourself and your
qualifications because you have
many thank you very much um first of all
uh my name is Stephen Petty and I I just
have a couple of opening remarks I'd
like to thank uh uh chairman Barbara
coma as well as the committee for the
chance to speak this morning uh and I
think I'll provide you with a long uh
but quick summary of the actual science
on masking social distancing harms
caused by both and what are the real
solutions and I've actually implemented
those I've been doing this on a pro bono
basis now for four years um spoke to
dozens of not hundreds of folks uh to
try to to put the right Solutions in
place uh my goal over the next hour or
so is to quickly cover materials which
I've provided to you um and then have
time to take questions this is a little
different group so if there's something
that um subject to the Chairman's
instructions if you would like to ask a
question at some point in the slide I
think we have the time to do so maybe
that's
appropriate um yes if anyone would like
to do that um let me first say that my
overall
um uh position uh as a subject matter
expert on exposure exposure control and
personal protective equipment is
that uh you'll find that the science on
masking social distancing is not
supported by the science going back over
hundred years and actually causes great
harm to both adults and children but the
real solution has been the solution
that's existed for almost a hundred
years which is engineering controls and
that it's very simple it's diluted
filtered out or kill it and I'm going to
show you actual technologies that I've
implemented and followed uh both in
terms of what they are and what they
cost um
um I'm not a big fan of talking about
qualifications because I've been working
now 45 years which is too long I need to
retire but um here are a few um I'm a
professional engineer in Six States um
I'm what they're called a certified
industrial hygienist which is a high
level expert on health and safety and
I'm a certified Safety Professional I
think there's only a couple hundred of
us that have all three credentials in
the United
States as I will show medic medical
doctors are not subject matter experts
for exposure and exposure control and
PPE this is not well understood by the
public uh in my 45 years of
experience uh including the last 20
testifying in nearly 400 cases
named um I've never had a medical doctor
do my job that is to do exposure levels
exposure control and PE person
protective uh they with equipment what
they do is they take my exposure and
they make a determination as to whether
or not that cause their disease so
unfortunately we have a lot of
Physicians and they may be super well
qualified in their own areas but they
talk a lot about exposure and exposure
control and frankly the vast majority
don't know what they're talking
about um I've sampled for all manner of
pathogens Anthrax biotoxins dioxin
pesticides mold bacteria voc's Benzene
asbest Etc so I'm actually a Hands-On
guy I'm not just a person that will talk
to you about
uh some of the academic sides of it
although I certainly worked in that area
as well um for the past 20 years as I
said I've been in disclosed I've worked
on more disclosed in over 400 cases on
exposure control PPE and warnings the
most recently I was selected as the
expert for the East Palestine train
accident so I'm the lead expert on that
as well as I'm the I've been selected to
be the exposure expert on Roundup
paraquat uh C8 the first of the I was on
stand and four trials for 12 days for
those as well as the P forever chemicals
Arena I'm the expert on that for the 3M
case that just settled for 12 billion as
well as U I'm now I was named yesterday
as expert for the state of North
Carolina
work um it should be noted that while
I've spent almost all my career
protecting workers in the public if I
thought for a minute that m
uh or n95s would protect individuals or
the public from a virus I'd be right
there that's been my job my whole
career and they don't it's a fraud it's
a complete fraud on the public and I'll
show you this there are real solutions
and I think it the masking came from the
concept that some folks were um using
the concept that we all want to try to
do our part and help in a pandemic and
they they played on people's desire to
help as opposed to what the real science
was with that um let me get started
[Music]
um I just want to spend a second talking
about industrial hygiene
because there's there's only about
10,000 industrial hygienist which you
div to 50 states it's about 200 that are
certified and it's really the Art and
Science science associated with the
anticipation recognition evaluation
control of things that will make you
sick make you uncomfortable and even
kill
you and that's our job we we go into the
field if people aren't feeling good or
there's a problem or people have died we
try to figure out what it was that that
uh hurt them or killed them and what can
we do to stop it and so we we unlike the
medical field we have to take this world
of things that could be impacting people
and winnow it down and then use the r
reports are used by the medical
community to see whether or not it
actually hurt the
individual
um let me see if I can move this so it's
a field associated with uh exposure
personal protective equipment and
warnings and it's as I said it's it's
the problem is of course the media is
dependent upon MDS to talk about
industrial hygiene issues and that's
been a problem uh as I said earlier in
all of my exposure cases I've never had
an MD my job and uh so that's just it
needs to the public needs to understand
there is a difference now let's talk
real quickly about
masking does it work or not and it
really can be evaluated two levels the
first level is the macro or
epidemiological level I call it the
10,000 foot level and that's what most
of the public has heard about and then
there's the micro level the industrial
hygiene level and it's generally not
understood by the public but we're going
to talk about it real quick
this uh slide and like you'll find on
all these slides what I've tried to do
on the bottom is I put URLs so that if
you want to independently look at
anything I've
said those links will gift you right to
the original studies or the original
information um I try to be fully
transparent and all this so this is a
plot for New Hampshire and you can do
this for any state and I have um of the
cases of covid with time and if you
thought especially in the early days
that masking would do some good then you
would expect that cases would drop as
soon as masks mandates were implemented
but they don't what you tend to see here
is that in Northern climates they peak
in the winter months guess what when
people are trapped
indoors um and then they in the southern
climates you tend to have some peaks in
the summer when people are indoors with
air conditioning in the southern
hemisphere it's just the opposite and
what these curves really are what's a
concept called fars curve and this was
from Dr far in 1836 seven and and what
he showed this I'll show this next plot
is that diseases tend to the cases tend
to rise rapidly reach a peak and then
Decay away this is the concept of fars
curve so interestingly enough I've
overlaid some Mass mandates in in
California on the fars curve uh and you
see that they were implemented on the on
the left side or beginnings of the
pandemic and guess what they really were
effective weren't they the case is
skyrocketed um now if they had have been
really clever they would have
implemented them on the backs side of
the farest curve because then the cases
would have dropped but I don't think it
would have had much to do with
masking let's talk about epidemiological
the 10,000 foot
level the
uh and by the way as a certified
industrial hygienist I'm an expert in 18
disciplines including toxicology and
epidemiology
um the probably the uh the best studies
that you can look at are what they call
randomized control trials and they says
where you have a group two groups one as
similar as can be in one group you
implement a change on the other you
don't and you see in this case if you
added Mass to half a group and not to
the other half does a rate at which they
get infected say with covid change at
least
statistically and um the least desirable
studies what we call observational
studies well I had a friend that did
this and they didn't get sick or did get
sick you know that's not there could be
all kinds of factors that impact why
they got sick or where they were um
Cochrane did a study recently where
Jefferson was the primary author where
they did a meta study of the rcts
related to masking both mass and
n95s and um an art so what they did is
they looked at all the rcts as a group
they call that that's about the best
study you can do and um what did they
find and I'll just read
this medical surgical mask versus no
mask wearing masks in a community
probably makes little or no difference
to the outcome of laboratory confined
covid versus not wearing a mask and then
what did they say about
n95s well the n95s were comparable to
surgic masks I.E they didn't do any
better than no masks in fact I'll show
you a study coming up where masks
actually do more harm than not wearing a
mask with respect to
co so um he based his meta analysis on a
series of studies one was the bunder
guard study out of Denmark may I ask a
question really quickly yes ma'am is
this the study that was released in a
with data from April
uh are you referring to something I have
here I'm sorry no I'm just looking up
Jefferson at all cockran study and it
looks like this was released well it was
published in November 2020 but they were
only looking at studies done prior to
April 2020 so I'm just wondering about
how Rel these are no no this one isn't
there was an initial rain study but
this is the followup I think it
published in the fall of
uhhuh yeah I know what you're talking
about that's an early study earlier
one
um the bunder guard study and again the
URLs here if you want to look at
yourself they looked at roughly 6,000
people 3,000 with mass 3,000 without
masks the bottom line was that masking
didn't have an effect on reducing rates
of
covid Benny spear in Europe looked at
this is busy I understand but bottom
line is he he correlated um rate of mask
wearing by country versus deaths from
covid and what he found was countries
with the highest rate of maske wearing
had the highest rates of death from
covid similarly in us uh fogan did the
same thing with counties in Kansas and
found the same thing that those counties
with highest rates of mask wearing were
um had the highest rates of covid
deaths
um the other thing that that uh and we
know this as an industrial
hygienist the mask is a perfect breeding
ground for amplification of bacteria
molds even some trap virus because it
provides a for those elements that are
breathed out and contained it has
perfect conditions of temperature and
humidity for amplification of mold
bacteria Etc to give you an examp
example if you can't see mold on a wall
you know there's no visible mold we've
all seen visible mold on things the
support count is on the order of 10,000
spores per square inch or less that's
background but if you see mold you
actually can see it the counts are over
a million so we're not talking about
going from less than 10,000 to 20,000
when you start to see it we're talking
about massive increases exponential
increases so what happens to somebody is
that if you wear a mask you're to some
degree you're breathing out always
breathing out pathogens uh whether it be
strep or or all kinds of things and
they're released at low levels uh the
body's constantly fighting off things
but if they're trapped on this mask and
then they amplify by a factor of a 100
and then they're
rebreathed it's no surprise your immune
system is being challenged and weakened
so you're going to be more susceptible
to opportunistic diseases and that's
what this study shows this is a December
2023 paper pretty
recent and it says basically that um
you're going to see rates of increase in
covid of between 33 and
40% higher if you wear a mask versus not
wearing a
mask that's not a surprise to me because
you would expect
that how about masking in schools do
they work series of studies on this um
Florida schools they had schools
districts where Mass were warn versus
school districts where they were
not um this is busy I understand it but
basically These Bars um are the air
bands and then the data for people with
mask and without mask and the data
overlap so there's basically no
difference very recently there was a
study um published in 20 late
2023 by S hikes Stevenson and hog and
they had a really unique situation they
had two school districts Fargo and West
Fargo North Dakota one District required
masks the other did not and this is a
plot of cases of disease with time in
those districts of course you see the
forest curve kick off we're in the dead
of winter you have the most
cases but bottom line was there was no
difference
now the issue with respect to children
and masking and this an issue I've been
pounding on for 3 or four years and I'll
talk more about this in a
second they look this is a a detailed
analysis of uh in 2023 now of impacts on
children um one they say the science
does not support the use of masks for
covid for children and two it causes
great harms uh I should add that I got
involved in this in the fall of 2020
when a school special needs high school
with 900 autistic children in
Westerville Ohio contacted me the school
Master did Dr Morrison and she said I I
don't want to put the kids in Mass it
they won't wear them and it'll hurt
their learning because they really
depend on seeing people uh speaking and
and watching their
faces what can we do and I said well
we'll do the same thing we always did
we'll we'll increase the Fresh Air
Supply we'll impact your humidity
control in the in the shoulder months
fall and and spring and then we're going
to put in new Co uh new Calon eyeway
which I don't think has a lot of side
effects but destroys 99% of the virus
mold in bacteria and um that's what we
did we had a lot of push back as you can
well imagine from the state of Ohio
Board of
Education in the um fall of 2020 this
was a time where people were petrified
about
covid um and um we did it anyway
um the um
the state let us do it we had almost no
covid in fact the only time they had an
outbreak of covid was after an incident
where the maintenance people came in and
changed out the filters but forgot to
turn the systems back
on and as soon as they turned them back
on the the co rate dropped to nothing
the more important point is now three
years later the test scores have
remained at or above what they were
before
covid now what you'll find in districts
where they wore masks and did social
distancing you see upwards of a quarter
year per year of Education
lost it's pretty
sad so the other the other thing and
I've testified in federal court on this
um everybody wants to cite the CDC
studies almost all of them cited for
covid are not randomized control studies
they're
observational what's that mean they
don't have a control group that is a
group that not wearing masks versus a
group that is wearing masks
and moreover they have co-founding
factors meaning that they're not
controlling for other things in other
words does the difference is it they may
be wearing masks but are they also doing
quarantining of sick people social
distancing changing the HVAC system Etc
if you're if you're changing all those
things how do you know what the impact
the mask will have you
don't um and what's fascinating is in
May of 20 I think it's March or may of
2020 CDC put out out a meta study on
whether or not masking helped uh stop
cases of influenza now viruses by and
large are all the same size they're very
small I'll show this in a second and
they concluded conclusively they made no
difference it just seems to be that that
within two or three months they lost
track of all the work they just
published now I appreciate that I'm an
expert on on protecting workers in the
public
so this sometimes comes as a surprise to
people that I would be against masking
but the reality
is and for things that actually help
people not things that hurt people um if
you don't mind just a quick question so
we see a lot of times um in hospital
settings and things um that people are
wearing masks and sometimes they're not
um and from what I'm understanding what
you're saying is a lot of these viruses
cannot be um you cannot be protected
from Mass no matter where you are is
that correct is that an assumption am I
understanding it correctly yeah there's
and this has led to confusion and and
for good reason the reason that doctors
wore sucal masks is to stop against
large droplets of blood and body fluids
now all particles can be split into two
camps the big guys are call them the big
guys which are droplets that are greater
than five microns and the little guys
which we call aerosols which are less
than five microns in fact they're called
respirable particles meaning they reach
the Deep lung and that's what causes
disease as I'll show in a second
99% or more of the co particles are
aerosols so while it is true that mass
can stop droplets to some degree it's
it's shining the the laser pointer to
the wrong
place and the real issue and and this
has been pointed out in my letter along
with six other scientists to CDC as well
as a letter before that from I think 25
scientists saying look you're you're
really deceiving the public about this
Mass Stop droplets because the issue
isn't droplets it's aerosols the little
guys and this is largely not understood
by our our Public Health officials as
well as people making policy yes sir
okay uh I'm not aware of cases so I want
to ask you mentioned that when we see
mold it means increase of like 100 uh so
were there actually cases when people
were wearing masks to the extent that
mold was seen on masks or uh could you
expand yeah I mean I've I've testified
on how many mold cases and then I dozens
of mold cases but I just give it as a
point of reference that um when I say
amplification I don't mean we're
doubling the rate from say mold being
visible to non-visible it's going up by
a factor of 10 to 100 so the problem of
course with that is you're going to
rebreathe that stuff back in right
you've discharged it at say let's call
it a level of one and now it's going to
come back into your body at a level of
10 to 100 well it's it doesn't you don't
have to have a degree to realize that
that's gonna your immune system is going
to react to that and react strongly and
it's it's gonna
weaken it because it's got to fight off
this
stuff um and then it makes you more
vulnerable obviously to anything else
that comes
along
yes thank you for being here um I wanted
to ask you about something that I I saw
some time ago uh regarding a study that
sort of popped up and then disappeared
so to set the frame obviously I can
understand why people going into this
would think that a mask could be
effective
in general because well it stops you
know some stuff from coming out but in
order to look at all the you know other
you know things that could happen there
was this one study I saw it it suggested
that as you were saying this whole
amplification effect that happens within
masks could actually cause a much higher
viral load to build up in the mask that
then when either forcefully exhaled or
coughed into the Mas mask could cause uh
huge amounts of Aer isolation of the
virus from The Mask to the environment
is that something you you've heard of or
have any familiarity with I'm aware of
of that work that argues that because
the mask in terms and we'll talk about
the particle sizes coming up here but
the mask if you will Envision it as a a
big
screen and so you get these drop what
droplets are formed then have to wedge
their way through the screen and are
broken up and that is true the bigger
issue though is
the uh we'll get to this but the drop
they're so small a mass by definition
cannot be sealed and I'll talk about
that because a mass that can be sealed
is called a
respirator and there in lies the problem
uh so let me continue on the on the
sorry can I just ask what what's the
mechanism that you're proposing for how
a virus is going to be Amplified inside
a mask they need
cells the the mechanism is that when you
have um if you look at at conditions
where biologics amplify in other words
grow whether it be a a virus mold or
bacteria um two conditions uh are really
important one is the moist that there's
moisture present because if it's very
dry things don't grow viruses don't just
amplify on their own they need to be
inside cells to grow so you're saying
that there's like no no no I'm talking
inside the mask that the vir I'm not
talking about the virus I'm talking
about the mold and the bacteria okay but
we're talking about Co I understand but
I'm talking about the fact that that
those things when Amplified weaken the
immune system so that when you do get
exposed to covid a virus you have
enhanced rate at which you're going to
get
sick okay I'm sorry if I didn't clarify
that as much as I should
have now let's talk a little bit about
the micr scale because this is a side
that you don't hear about so much you
hear a lot of the is back and forth on
epidemiological studies right that some
show it does some say it doesn't I the
real studies I think show it that is
that they're not effective masking
anyway so just by way of reference if
we've probably all seen this uh
especially if you have a day with
sunlight in in a room where there's dust
floating around dancing around and you
look up and see it that visible dust and
sunlight's around on the order of 50
microns or larger okay now if you look
at the covid
particle imagine that this uh white
cylinder is the diameter of a human hair
cross-section now that red dot isn't the
size of Co it's 10 times the size of Co
so I can show it to you so in terms of
diameter the co particle approaches a
thousand times
smaller the question I ask people
constantly is can you get a human hair
by the side of your m a mask well on
either side of your nose and below your
eyes almost all anybody can you can get
hundreds of hairs past it in fact you
see a lot of men wearing facial hair so
this is a super freeway around the ma
Let's ignore whether the mask is
effective or not we'll get to that in a
second as soon as you have gaps at all
they basically the master are
ineffective and and and um so that's why
it could never have
worked now let's talk a little bit about
the size of these particles remember I
said before the the the big issue and
the big lie is that Co is a
droplet it's an aerosol primarily it's
not that there's not zero droplets it's
just as Edward shows and he did this
study with uh green monkeys primates not
humans because you you're not really
allowed today to experiment on humans
not not you're not supposed to anyway
but primates are the next best
um uh they're the best animals really to
study to see whether or not the effects
will translate to
humans and this is a little busy but the
bottom line is they you see that the
particle sizes as the person as the
monkeys were infected go up as you would
expect but in terms of
size over 99% of the particles were
aerosols or less than five
microns so the problem wasn't about
droplets the problem was how do we
control
aerosols and this has
been um as I said this was one of the
big statements we made in my letter to
CDC and to Dr fouchi in the white house
now what does this mean in the real
world there's a thing called Stokes law
that you can run and um it's basically
if you have still air and you know the
size of a particle and you know its
density how fast will it fall what's the
settling velocity so I said well what's
a settling velocity from five how long
would it take for a particle of
different sizes to fall five feet which
is kind of from somebody's nose
down for big droplet particles 10 to 100
microns the time to fall is somewhere on
the order of of less than a minute to to
minutes um but what happens when the
particles get
little well now our now our SC isn't
basically minutes it's
days think about that days so a CO
particle is on the order around 0.1
microns or so we're talking about 40 to
days so I always said to people when
they first started putting out the six
foot uh distance I called those the
dummy
dots because first of all a particle
that going to stay suspended and that's
assuming you don't stir up
again uh for that long of time it
certainly doesn't have a stop sign on
saying okay I'm at 6 feet I'm not going
any further now the other thing is I
spent three years looking for any data
supporting the sixf foot rule and could
never find
any now it turns out later on as I'll
show that fouchy and others have
admitted that it was made up no surprise
to me because I couldn't find any papers
on it for a year and a half and I'm
pretty thorough researcher
now the other thing that's done with
masking and we'll show it in a second
this is a busy plot I don't expect you
to understand all of it drunck was an
honest broker he said look we're not
going to show you mask Effectiveness by
almost all the studies glue The Mask to
a board or a
mannequin and I asked people do you glue
your mask to your face I I don't know
anybody does that I I heard of one case
it was kind of stupid but he actually
looked at what happens if there's gaps
in The Mask how how does it decrease the
effectiveness of the
mask and what this plot shows is that
for surgical
masks that if what he did is he looked
at well what if you had say 100 square
centimeters of a mask and you assumed 1%
of it 1 centimeter was was a gap 1% Gap
how does that drop the effectivess of
the mask and then he looked at 2% Etc
and at 2% and the in the correlation is
pretty linear the mass dropped in its
Effectiveness by
80% well I said well that's interesting
why don't I just project that line out
to where it's
0% well it's 3% of mask area
open the mask has zero
Effectiveness now I actually took my
Spirit Airlines mask and measured the
gaps on my own face
crudely was
9%
so they had no chance now there was some
discussion earlier about viruses
bacteria Etc this is a a chart and the
reason I show it is you'll see on the
bottom is dated 1992 I'm a member of
what they call ashray American Society
of heating Refrigeration air
conditioning Engineers I've been a
member of that for 40 years and in fact
I'm on the committee right now updating
this
table
um and viruses turned out to be a really
really small particle relative to even
bacteria and and mold spores I mean they
their bacteria are probably 10 to 20
times
bigger so we're dealing with very very
small
particles so what does all this mean it
means that the little that the issue has
always been about I call them the little
guys the aerosols not the big guys the
droplets the vast majority of the
particles are the little guys the little
guys stay in the air for hours to days
and they reach deep into the lung and
are associated with disease
so the real information was that CDC
said Mass Stop droplets may be true to
some degree but the problem isn't
droplets it's
aerosols so the other question I got
asked in in Trials about this and in
public forums is well you know Mr Petty
aren't you saying that are you saying
these will do no good that's the classic
lawyer question
right and I said well first of all it's
not standard of care our standard of
care as industrial hygienist is that the
um whatever solution we propose should
reduce the risk by at least 90% why do I
say that let's imagine that I propose a
solution that that uh stops asbestos
workers 1% of them from getting
asbestosis and the other 99% get it and
die well I should lose all my
credentials if I did that that's not
really looking out for the public health
safety is
it so and the other Parable I give all
the time is let's imagine you have an
engineer and a mathematician in a
room and the moderator says okay look at
that far wall and move halfway to it and
then move halfway again and move halfway
forever and then he asked each of them
the question did you get to the
wall mathematician says no the engineer
says yep close enough
so when somebody asks me are masks 0%
effective I say probably not but they're
darn
close and moreover our standard of care
is that we need to protect the vast
majority of people with our Solutions
not a minority not a small
minority and the bigger problem with
masks is they do they they they convince
people they're doing some good but then
they um don't go and take on the real
solutions so here's here's a plot here's
a picture of uh CD CDC has this on their
website of the STM face covering
standard that's how they test face masks
they glue them onto a
board now even with an n95 they'll say
okay if it's glued on the board it's 46%
effective we'll argue whether that's
true or not as soon as they put a gap on
it
3.4%
surgical Mass cloth Mass from from this
work uh around 10% or less that's not a
solution for us it just isn't and the
reason I say that is we got away with it
with covid because The lethality rate
was so low on the order of
.2% mainly with elderly over
65 if if anybody recalls when Ebola hit
and we had some PE some people um
workers in Africa coming back remember
the PPE that was being worn by the the
people working with those people it was
level a moon we call Moon
Suits now if Co had had a 50%
lethality people would have been
throwing these masks away in two seconds
because half their friends would be dead
so the problem we had was that nobody
really knew whether they were working or
not because The lethality was so
low
so you know I was saying this back in
2020 I've helped hundreds of people I
don't know why because it was taking me
two to six hours a day along with my
full-time job but I would go anywhere
and help anyone that I could because I
felt so strongly that the public was
being misled on real
solutions so it's just not Steve Petty
saying this we have Scott G godle who's
now with fiser but he was former FDA
commissioner and he says this on CBS
faal Nation
um in early 202020 2022 pardon me cloth
masks aren't going to provide a lot of
protection that's the bottom line This
is an Airborne illness we understand
that a cloth mask is not going to
protect you from a
virus not a surprise to me but we
finally got some
truth more recently uh Dr jaaw out of
the White House the co uh director ctor
said um there's no study in the world
that show Mass work now I I don't know
that I would agree with them I think
there's been plenty of very questionable
studies that suggest that they do but no
reasonable study does this isn't a
surprise by the way
um uh there was a gentleman Dr Kellogg
who ran the California health system
during the Spanish Flu pandemic in
1918 and he had advocated masking and on
page 26 of his report in 1919 kind of on
Lessons Learned he shows a plot of uh I
believe it it's a city in Massachusetts
where masking wasn't worn versus a city
in California they
were basically no difference in death
rates and he says you know the masking
doesn't work for the public now he still
what confuses some people is he still
was not against masking and hospitals
but that was for the big
droplets a different argument you always
got to remember that because is the
people that advocate for Mas will say
well see the people in the hospitals we
them it's a very powerful argument but
it's for big body fluids the study after
study and I can cite them for you
say whether a physician when a physician
wears a mask it doesn't lower his rate
of getting or transmitting infectious
diseases nor does it for the patient
this is to stop big droplets either from
the doctor or from the patient like big
Globs of blood spum Etc it has nothing
to do with infectious
diseases and most recently uh there's
been
um some work being done on whether
masking should be done in hospitals and
cdc's Eric Stone this is very recent
just said basically mask don't work now
CDC wasn't happy with him about it
but that's what he
said and then
um you know CDC is funny saying this now
I wanted to show you this is the actual
data from 1919 the plot of uh a city
where Mass were warn in terms of death
rates in the city where they
weren't so I say to people I'm not some
Noel laate this information has been
known for a long time over a hundred
years and um people just needed to be
made aware of
it so a couple of things I've run into
in in court cases is uh Public Health
officials will say well I'm just
following CDC
guidance which I think is a copout
frankly because I said to them well
which guidance are you
following the guidance in early 2020
that mass aren't needed later in 2020
that they dar needed later in 2021 that
they aren't needed and then now again
well they're really not so good let's go
to
n95s so I say to people what science
changes its position on a topic 180
Mass no Mass two times in two
years there is no science that does
that not that I'm aware
of if you want to look at uh what really
would work in terms of PPE and I'm not
advocating PPE by the way and you look
at the Criterion in uh the respiratory
protection standard OSHA 29 cfr1
1910.134 and I've testified on this over
times on this standard
um you'll find that the criteria for
wearing a respirator are listed here and
almost none of those criteria apply to a
mask I'm not going to bore you with all
the
details so what caused me to write the
letter to
CDC how long I guess I was the primary
author what happened in early 2022 or so
was that CD saidwell you know those
maths aren't so great so let's move to
n95s
well first of all as a as an exposure
exert n95s are the bottom of the barrel
respirators but they were advocating
that that the respirators n95s could be
used by children well I knew right away
that was fallacious because no
respirator has ever been approved by
nios for used by children
ever so what did CDC they they they say
well if you want to know more about this
go over there and link to 3 website or
mold X's website and get more
information so I did I'm probably one of
the few that did what did it say what
did 3M say about masks or
n95s not designed to be used by children
so you got CDC paragraph advocating n95s
for children go to this link to see more
what does the manufacturers say not for
children you can't make this stuff
up and they said only designed for
adults and occupational settings and
trained I.E respiratory protection
standard and that adults must be
medically cleared to wear an n95
respirator in other words we got to make
sure they don't have some underlying
like we always do for respirators they
don't have some underlying health
condition that would hurt them if they
had their breathing somewhat restricted
by a respirator yes ma'am uh yes Mr py
thank you um when it says here that they
need to be trained to wear those masks
could you just explain to me why you
would need to be
trained yeah there's
um by training it's really broader than
that you need somebody usually an
industrial hygienist but somebody with
my expertise or or like that when you're
going to put uh what the um what the
respiratory protection standard says is
first of all you got to do a hazards
analysis what does that mean that means
you have to figure out what is the
contaminant that you're concerned about
and what is its concentration because
until you know that you don't know what
to provide them with protective
equipment so that sets the stage for
what will work now I'm here to tell you
mask and n95s won't be picked why
because n95s are prohibited for use by
asbest workers by law in California for
example asbestos particles are 50 times
greater than Co particles so why in the
heck would we ever promote masks or n95s
for particles that are much smaller than
particles where they're prohibited
now the other part of that is um once
you decide you that you've picked the
right PPE say a mask or a respirator I
should
say you have to have that selected and
fit tested for the individual in other
words um for instance the the two major
providers of respirators are north and
3M I can never get a 3M to seal on my
face it just doesn't seal I have to wear
a north and I have to wear a large
somebody else might have to wear a
medium or somebody have to wear a small
so you have to have all those available
and you have to try them out on people
and make sure that they do
seal so you got to pick the right
equipment you got to make sure it works
and then you have to train the
individual on how to store it how to
clean it how to often to change the
cartridges
Etc
yes thank you I this is really good
information um that I want to dig a
little bit into
I was injured uh badly in an industrial
accident a smoke inhalation injury
before which I had respirator quals but
after which I had my respirator quals um
pulled because of a lung condition that
I developed that prohibits me from being
able to wear a respirator so I just
wanted to get down into that a little
bit to suggest that there is at least
hypothetically um caused to believe you
could you could do harm by requiring
Hing people who were not medically able
to um wear masks and respirators yes
that's correct before as an industral
hygienist the first thing I have to
check on for the worker is have they
been medically cleared to wear a
respirator if they haven't then I can't
it's my job to prevent them from any
going any further in the process they
have to be excluded and in fact I've
testified in many cases where a
physician um said no this person's got
whether it be smoking or some chronic
lung
disease they they don't pass what they
call the F tests on lung capacity or
lung function and so they can't wear
respirator and then you've had the
company's industrial hygienist approve
them for use of the respirator now
that's that'll get you in
trouble I'm sorry did that
help thank you so much for being here um
I just had a question concerning time
frame wise uh I have a very good friend
that does um that does cleanup work with
asbestos and mold and all of that kind
of stuff and has um you know his
employees and how long because it's only
a certain amount of time that you can
wear them for correct like it's not you
can't wear them for very long periods of
time right before you have to take a
break no that's not true okay um but I
will say a couple of things in my
opinion personal protective equipment
should only be used for we'll get into
this in a second it's on the Bottom Rung
of ways we want to protect people it's
in my view it's really a temporary
emergency sort of situation where you
want to wear it and the reason for that
is we've known for decades that wearing
say a respirator or any PPE is
cumbersome and uncomfortable
particularly in hot or cold settings and
people will break the seals they won't
wear it properly um and so it's not
effective
so the any I've done it but most people
haven't try to wear I know I used to
have to go up where there was a lot of
bird dooo Etc and addicts and I would I
was always more worried about bacteria
than than mold but I would wear a
respirator and it'd be 110 degrees in
that attic you try to wear a respirator
for more than 15 or 20 minutes and
you're you can be in tremendous shape
and it's very
difficult yes so there is no
specific limitation on how long you can
wear it but there's a reality that uh if
you try to put people in respirators
that have eight hour shifts say day
after day after
day you're dishonest if you think you're
actually protecting them yeah that's why
he gives his workers breaks and things
like that and I'm familiar I was um in
the military in the Army and one of my
jobs was NBC uh so so I was um 94 Bravo
decontamination unit so I've spent a lot
of time in my gas mask and um so it was
horrible I always told people early on I
said let's remember when when people
were having to wear masks you go to a
restaurant and they'd make you put the
mask on and then you sit down and then
you take it off and you eat and drink or
whatever and I'm like so I said let's
imagine that this mask is perfect and
that room's full of nerve agent because
I worked a nerve agent in my previous
career at Patel and I said and it will
kill you pretty quickly yep I said so
you got I'm not saying this is true but
your PP your mask is perfect it's been
helping you there and then you take it
off to
eat with a lethal material
[Music]
present how does that make any
sense I mean this is just defies common
sense so you had to know at that point
in time it was
effective all righty
enough so um what else does the warnings
this is from the 3M label on
n95s you can go look it up failure to
follow instructions may result in
sickness or
death must follow the respiratory
protection standard we've talked about
that must be able to be sealed or do not
use a mask cannot be sealed by
definition in fact the face covering
standard uh
bym says in it
explicitly face coverings isn't a fancy
word for Mass are not
PPE and are not
protective remember I I I want stuff to
be protective now social distancing this
drove me crazy for
years and I would remind CDC all the
time they had no basis for this 6 foot
rule
so finally they cited a study in 2020
late
2021 this is it and fascinatingly that
you won't be able to see all the detail
here but it was a it was a study in
China all the units are in metric none
of them convert to six
feet and more importantly on this if you
look at where the person that got sick
was um there were people that got sicker
even close to the supply of fresh
air so I pointed that out that first of
all there it was all in metric there was
nothing the St had nothing to do with
six feet it had to do with people
getting sick in a
restaurant and um so you know they left
that up for like a year and then then we
had our Infamous friend Scott gotle who
said uh well about the 20 the 6ot rule
he says nobody know knows where it came
from I
said yeah no
kidding and then uh Dr fouchy very
recently January
24 yeah we it lacks scientific evidence
that's pretty scary honestly that we had
people in lines fighting each other
because they were closer than six feet
and weren't standing on the
dots I mean how sad is that yeah than
thank you and that's a that's a good
point I just read a little further in
that and he mentions that there is an
assumption among them that it may have
come from something old regarding the
flu where maybe the flu doesn't travel
six feet so I I my question is and I
don't know if you you have this
information but is there reason to
believe based on our previous knowledge
of Corona viruses versus our knowledge
of the flu that Corona virus is going to
behave in that same way as the flu
regarding transmission aerosolization
the time it see suspended and
whatnot uh you asked multiple questions
so I'll try to answer both of them with
respect to the issue the last one First
Co and the flu from standpoint of
particles and transmission essentially
the same now when I was looking up for
any studies on any distancing I found
one study from the 30s and it had a
three-foot rule and it was based on
tuberculosis and on
droplets so it was a different disease
it was a bacteria much bigger part
articles and it was based on a different
distance but CDC and the rest of the the
scientific Community never cited that
work in
fact
um there
was there was some information
suggesting that past studies had looked
at distancing but then they never really
talk about that particular study and
what it what it applied to but to my
know there's never been any um support
for that and when you look at the the
basic size of particle suspension time
in the
air there's just no I say to people
let's imagine that that you're in a
store and somebody's really sick with
covid two days
earlier or even a day earlier and that
stuff can be suspended for weeks right
and then if you Stir It Up it's it's
longer than that because I'm talking
about still air and you walk in a day
later there's no way in the world you
have a covid meter on your chest telling
you oops there's a plume of
covid that was there's never going to be
a solution for that situation the only
solution as we'll get to was either
dilute it
out filter it out or destroy
it it's been the solution since 1950
it'll be the solution as far in the
future as I
know
now let me talk a little in the world of
industrial hygiene we live with this
chart it's called the hierarchy of
controls it's how we deal with almost
it's it's kind of like our little bible
it's how we deal with exposure to
hazards of any kind falling tripping
infectious
diseases and the things that are the
most important are on the top and
effective and the things that are least
effective are on the
bottom the least effective is PPE of
course masks don't even fit in there
because they can't be sealed they're not
PPE um and we should we would know that
right away this by the way was brought
to us by the national Safety Council in
1950 um so we already talked about PPE I
won't belabor that administrative
controls is a fancy way of saying let's
just keep you out of the bad area so
you're not there very long or at all
well if you're dealing with an
infectious disease it's kind of hard to
do that because you got the public right
so how you going to keep people out of
spaces and we do that with a bowl and
really toxic thing you know really
lethal things you know we very carefully
isolate those folks now the other the
next level up is engineering controls
I've already talked about that
dilute um filter
destroy the the best of all worlds would
be to either eliminate or substitute it
but it doesn't really apply to co it's
not like like I just I was finishing a
project on silic Co is yesterday for all
these workers are using artificial stone
and they're cutting it and they were
just say an epidemic of
silicosis and the obvious solution was
don't use
Silica use engineering you know use
artificial stone but don't use Silica
we've known for almost a hundred years
that this is preventable and we
shouldn't be doing that um and what did
I site in there hierarchy of controls so
this is a very I don't want to say simp
like I'm trying to demean people but
it's it's a very
straightforward way to think about how
to solve
problems and that's what we
use now cdc's approach of course in
2021 was the solution is masks and then
the solution beginning in 2022 was well
masks or not
n95s um but my solution has been since
engineering
controls and why I'm not a rocket
scientist it's been around long before I
was
around now damage the
children
um I'm not going to read through these
and and be a you know but they're all
here the um first of all this is the
study that shows of course that if you
wear masks you're going to increase the
rated disease so this applies not only
to children but to everyone but when you
look at
um child harms there are study after
study after study showing all sorts of
negative implications to children in
learning
psychologically
emotionally
learning I'm not going to go through all
those but even the even the who does not
allow masking for children below 11
without a cost benefit
analysis and there's no it's never been
run CDC has never run a cost benefit
analysis on masking versus not masking
in fact they require masking down to
age2 which is almost criminal in my view
because that's the Early Learning period
we know now on real work children ages 0
to two have had a 25% reduction in
learning
rates how fast they can say words Etc in
fact what's really disturbing is in
early
2022 CDC announced that they were uh
revising the Child Development criteria
that had been in place for 15 years and
what were they revising them to in about
40% of the cases they were moving the
gohost forward right so if you were
supposed to be able to say so many words
at 24 months now they moved them to 30
months I said this is this wasn't
revising this was this was covering up
the fact that you knew these were
harming children in their development
and rather than addressing the issue you
simply changed the criteria by which
when children had to know certain things
on
average it really was
unconscionable um so I'm not going to
belabor uh all the you can go on and on
and on about these studies this one by
curriculum Associates what's fascinating
is it looked at um loss of learning
learning uh grades 1 through 8 on
reading up to 12% reduction in learning
rates math up to
15% sadly for minorities the impact was
worse um and then we have a study here
I'm flipping through these quickly Brown
University for young people as I just
mentioned the learning composite score
dropped 23% around a quarter of a loss
of learning per year of
study
um both on non-verbal and
verbal England you know this wasn't just
in the United States we work out of
England says the same thing that the
teachers are saying
94% of them thought that wearing face
coverings has made it difficult for
children to
learn some over half said much more
difficult um there was a study by kizli
off uh or kizony I'm sorry looked at
1,26 papers uh related to impacts of
negative impacts of or impacts period of
of people wearing masks face coverings
they distilled it down to 109 papers
that had qualitative analysis and 44
that had quantitative analysis that they
felt were
reasonable you can see the URL on the
bottom if you want to go chase it down
yourself and they they discovered
27 Quantified adverse effects five
specific associated with
children impacts on respiratory U
diseases including asthma
cardiopulmonary neuromuscular and
epilepsy uh not not a surprise uh
basically when you affect um breathing
you affect all all the tissues from the
nose all the way to the Deep lung in
terms of negative impacts um Mr Petty
yeah if you don't mind I just have a
quick question for you would you say
that the uh um I don't know if you've
done any studies on this uh if special
needs have
risen uh because of this and uh children
with disabilities um has this really
adversely affected them you spoke about
a school that um with with disabilities
that they didn't wear masks and
everything seemed to be fine has there
been any studies to uh talk about the
schools that didn't with the PE the
students with
disabilities I haven't done that
personally but Dr Morrison whom I'm in
close contact with at this school and
she's spoken
publicly follows that because she has a
very unique program for treating
autistic children she her PhD know issue
at on treating it you know trying to
develop autistic children she's got a
very unique school for that and she has
commented to me over and over again that
the special needs students have been
more dramatically impacted in her
knowledge because she gets students all
the time coming from the public schools
that want to come to her school and
they've had real deficits that they've
had to try to overcome so it's it's
anodot to some degree but I haven't done
an independent study but I've talked to
somebody who's that is her work thank
you very much representative I I have
two questions if I may so first about
masks I'm aware about like one facility
in New Hampshire kind of daycare that
was not pushing Universal masks on kids
but uh Educators were wearing masks so
can you give any distinction because um
it would wouldn't be probably medically
harmful for kids if educator wears masks
but it might delay the education because
they don't see facial impression and the
pronunciation yeah yeah the real the
loss of learning has more to do with the
teachers wearing the masks than
necessarily the students because they're
they're reading facial
expressions so that you're you're
correct that that is that's one of the
primary reasons there's a deficit in
learning and my second question is more
like uh stepping back uh to the
beginning of your
presentation uh I just wonder
like uh if if you have certain dates
when um when the science appeared that
co uh is uh primarily spread uh VI
aerosols versus other and when when for
example well CDC
acknowledged it that Co is spread via
aerosols because in the beginning if you
remember there was like is it spread via
droplets many people thought it could
spread via touch so we were wearing some
recommending wearing plastic
gloves ear on everybody was yeah there
was the hygiene of you know touching
things and touching Packages Etc yeah
that was always kind of silly in my view
I mean not I'm not saying that
you couldn't get um Co that way but that
wasn't the primary way you're going to
co the primary way was going to be
through inhalation not through
dermal um but as far as time frame
goes um to my knowledge CDC has yet to I
keep all their web pages because they
take them down and replace them all the
time but I always save them I guess you
can go back and get them but I save them
anyway to my knowledge they still
haven't fully acknowledged this is
primar a dis primarily a disease of
aerosols
um they know this
because this they've
gotten multiple letters including the
one that's here from
me as well as six other scientists um
reminding them of that as well as there
was a letter that went out from 15 or 20
other epidemiologists a year before me
saying the same thing but more
importantly the science on um particle
sizes
for um say
flu which is a virus have always been
about the aerosols that
because your body has the the reason
that the science goes way back on
particles are always split between I
just wrote a a paper on this
yesterday if you will they can be
divided I call them the little guys and
the big guys but the little guys are
always called respirable to be breathed
in and the the big guys are called
non-resp and the split is five microns
or about and so what does that really
mean and this goes way back I mean this
is basic science what that means is that
when you get to a respirable size um
that's why you see like diesel exhaust
particles they're talking about 2.5
microns the ones that are small
right those get deep into the lung and
it's well understood in other words your
body has capacity from the nose to the
early stretches of the lung they have
vilia and other and and and mucus Etc to
trap and stop larger particles from
getting into your deep lung the problem
is when they get small enough that they
bypass those natural mechanisms and they
reach the Deep lung and that's why
you'll see I've cited some but there's
paper after paper going way back that
will say the small guys are the problem
because they're associated with disease
and they bypass Natural Body mechanisms
and they reach deep into the
lung so why why that's uh why we've had
you know the main purpose of my letter
here to CDC and I conclude by saying
you're damaging and destroying science
by doing this stuff the public isn't
going to trust you that's not a good
thing and we're here to help if you
would like that's we close the letter
saying look we're here to help now
appreciate I've always
worked on on the toxic Tor Arena
so um it's not like I've not been on
that side of the table trying to help
people um I'm not some crazy guy trying
to tell them their nuts I'm just saying
look you're really doing
harm to the to your position publicly as
a trusted Health
Organization and it's because you're
blatantly wrong on such simple
issues and that's that's and and I
pointed some of those out already um
even our Trade Organization the American
industrial hygiene Association
they very recently in
2023 cdc's decided they were going to
come out with some advice on how to
especially in medical
facilities um and that's one of our
biggest Problems by the way is that
people trust the white coats they trust
their doctors and they see the doctors
wearing
masks the B doctors are wearing masks
for these large droplets they're not
wearing them for covid and the problem
is it reinforces the message the wrong
message that mass
work but they're intended for different
purposes so anyway the CDC decided they
were going to continue to press this by
forcing masking and social distancing
and medical facilities for people
and I testified against it um and our
Trade
Organization uh came out publicly
against it and yesterday I read an
article that said that CDC was going to
delay implementing this so I'm hopeful
that they'll not Implement bad
science I I've kept telling them you
know the real answer is engineering
controls you know that and in fact
you'll see the language if you Pro if
you read their guidance from 2020 late
20 or 20 yeah 20 forward you'll start to
see them slowly add language related
engineering control it's kind of an
afterthought and you also see like on
page the first page they always say we
recommend masks or something to that
effect um interestingly they don't
require it now recommended is a
different word
legally but when you go like on page six
of these documents they'll admit masks
are not personal protective equipment
but they know most people aren't going
to read deep into these
documents Al righty see if I can get
this thing to move so the real solutions
I think you want you know nobody likes a
critic that doesn't have real solutions
so I want to talk about those for a
second as I've said before the real
solutions a straightforward fil add more
fresh air filter or destroy it
[Music]
um dilution ventilation has been around
forever people ask me early on when they
were afraid what can we do at
home I said well honestly I said open
windows I said if you open Windows
partly I know it be a little colder a
little hotter but I said you'll dilute
the concentration inside your house by
at least a factor of
10 so you know now what can you do in
commercial buildings it turns out
because of our energy codes I won't go
into all the details I've been involved
with that for 40 years we have
increasingly tightened
buildings with very little fresh air uh
a lot of recirculated air because we
want to minimize if you bring in fresh
air it's got to be treated and it jacks
up your uh cost for air conditioning or
Heating and so we're looking at
buildings that often times have only
five 5% Fresh Air Makeup so you're
basically just spinning the air in a big
circle and the contaminants are building
up right that's
why people get sick more indoors than
Outdoors because contaminants tend to
build up indoors by a factor of two to
four over what they would be
outdoors um that's why when we had
unnamed officials in New York City
saying stay in your multifam building
and don't go to the beach or to the
parks I about pull my hair out man the
most safe place in the world is to be
near a beach where you've got salt
aerosols and heavy dilution of any
contaminants I mean the last thing you
want is everybody ganged up together um
Mr Petty um glad you brought that up
that was a topic of uh con discussion
here because one of the things that New
Hampshire did was we shut down the
beaches um because we thought that there
would be too many people in one spot um
I know I can see your smiling um I'm
sorry I just understand the sanity of
that from my perspective is so could you
explain because you know I mean we went
into the social distancing aspect of
that already but you said that Salt
Air is that a benefit and does that help
dissipate things could you yeah I mean
the salt there's always salt aerosols
around especially around the oceans
right and salt is a is a desicant and it
tends to to destroy
bacteria and viruses because it extracts
their liquids but more importantly you
almost always have a
breeze and
the I can't think of an environment
where you have more fresh air and good
air as opposed to I mean
there I can site study after study
especially a lot amount of California on
fresh air and whether the rates of
buildup and contaminants inside spaces a
lot of work in that area on form
Malahide for example and um it's just we
know and and I showed that early on in a
macro sense that when do people tend to
get diseases when they're packed in
together when they're inside when the
concentrations are higher and two
they're closer together there's more
people closer together so the best thing
in the world is for people to be
outdoors spread out you know yeah would
you rather not have a bunch of people
right together I guess but I'd rather
have them together Outdoors than indoors
so
um I I think it would be very hard to
prove that many people got sick being
outdoors
yeah thank you um and part of what we're
looking here is is not just to look
backward but also to be able to develop
recommendations going forward which I
think is very useful here so on on that
line obviously you've talked about
ventilation if we can't ventilate
commercial buildings as much because we
want to keep them energy efficient we're
looking to uh filtration and also is
there any uh modern technologies that
have uh proven effective in eliminating
virus and bacteria in the air such as I
don't know UVC or anything like that yep
we're just about
there um I wouldn't discount in fact we
did it I I I told people straight out in
the schools let's override the um damper
controls on Commercial school
buildings um to allow maximum fresh air
in because we should end up diluting by
a factor of 10 or so now we will have
some humidity control issues in the
spring and in the
fall and we'll just have to deal with
that so that was my first solution the
second solution as you mentioned is is
um we'll get past that we've talked
about
it
um a second solution is destruction
and I looked at a series of Technologies
this is in 2020 and I've continued to
follow them um because a lot of times
when you go to solve a problem you
create another problem like early on
there was a big push to put Oz ozone
inside
spaces I was against it this goes back
in the 90s I was on a lot of committees
and I said no the problem is it's an
uncontrolled addition in other words the
problem when you added ozone in a in a
residential space and I it in my home is
there's no control it's like it's like
having a furnace without a
thermostat so you just the furnace comes
on and you're either really hot or and
it goes off and you're really cold well
you don't have a control on an ozone
generator so the ozone if you're in a
small house and you got a big ozone
system you put too much ozone in and it
it does its job it destroys
tissue but it destroys too much and I
walked around with a cough all the time
um or it's too small and it's not really
doing its job so it's uncontrolled I
didn't I didn't like it plus it causes
damage well there's a technology called
bipolar ionization technology uh there
are multiple vendors the one that's that
I know the most is new Calgon
iWave and it destroys up to 99% of
viruses but it also destroys mold and
bacteria as well they're about $400
they're easy to install the HB guys will
charge you 800 because they mark it up
but I've installed them in all my
businesses all my my homes my friends
homes um they're easy to install you
just need to know how to hook up a hot
and a cold I mean a you know a white and
a black and a ground to the fan circuit
they're magnetic they're about I don't
know this big maybe 4 by six in and you
slap them on the side of the fan the
squirrel cage
fan and voila they and it turns out
early on when I was pushing them the
data was a little iffy now ashr Journal
published in in 2021 actual data showing
that they they were uh getting rid of
somewhere around 90% of the bacteria per
pass and the virus so I that that's what
I recommended in the school in the fall
2020 they continue to use them as long
as well as increased ventilation so
that's one solution on destruction
um people have talked about using
ionized hydrogen peroxide that's a
little more complicated but it does work
you'll see in all these I've showed what
the reduction what the capacity is what
they cost
Etc
[Music]
um there's also I don't know if I have
it here yeah ultraviolet is another one
UVC um it definitely works the only
issue with UVC is
you you have to have somebody
maintaining it in the sense that you got
to constantly or at least periodically
make sure it's still working the bulbs
haven't burned out my experience I was
director of R&D for Columbia Gas in
charge of residential and Commercial is
that we have a heck of a time our our
appliances we plan on people doing
nothing to them because it'll be years
before they change filters in some cases
so just knowing human nature UVC
definitely works as well um it's another
I think it's one of the two best Sol
Solutions probably better in a
commercial industrial setting where you
have maintenance scheduled
maintenance the other area is
filtration and um I'm not as for this as
the other two uh for a couple reasons
one um all filters are are given what
they call uh a Merv rating minimum
efficiency reporting
value and your typical HEPA filter had
the higher the number the tighter the
filter the harder it is for stuff to get
through it but also there's more
pressure drop so it takes more energy
fan energy to push the air pull the air
through
it well it turns out that most HEPA
filters are have um Ms that are you know
down around 8 n to to separate these
small particles you're going to get
you're going to have to have a mve
that's at least 16 the problem with that
is that for especially in a residential
setting or a small business
setting the fan motor would not be
sufficient to pull the air through there
it would be it would be really hard so
you'd have to replace the fan motor that
becomes
expensive um and so um the biggest issue
in my mind is that you would have to
really update the mechanical systems and
that that is the way hbac people do is
they don't like to modify stuff they
like to replace it so then it becomes
expensive uh don't like ozone um there's
some stuff called photo catalytic
oxidation in the research stages looks
to be super effective but it's not
commercially
available and then silver has always
been known as a uh as a bioside
interestingly enough the reason that
priests and ministers use chalises with
silver in them is it kills
biologics most people didn't know that
um so nanop particles of silver on in
fact interestingly enough a lot of the
[Music]
um uh filters the high efficiency
filters or or that are being put in
saying they kill uh moldar bacteria or
viruses they're all coated with a thin
layer of silver by the way very
thin
so um with that I'm not going to I think
we've had a chance for me to cover some
of the comments I've had the the bottom
line is mask and n95s can't and will
never be the solution to infectious
diseases the solutions are
filtration
um uh more fresh air or destruction they
always have been and um they always will
be in the future and I appreciate the
opportunity to talk to you folks and um
I'm welcome to answer any questions you
might have yes ma'am
representative thank you and thank you
for being here appreciate it
um for a typical classroom
size how many of these
devices or would you you know would it
take to deal with that how much would it
cost say per
classroom to kill off
the viruses it depends on if you had um
a central system in other words system
supplying multiple classrooms then you
could have put this new cowon on that
and the new kgon would is um it handles
about equivalent of four tons rule of
thumb of cooling so for the rule of
thumb is 800 foot per ton so that's 3200
sare
feet so that's going to cover multiple
classrooms so if you had a wing of
classrooms one unit would do that yes
now there's there's some technology that
I put in here for Standalone systems
that have been implemented in Texas yeah
that's in in here in New Hampshire we
have a lot of old school buildings that
are heated with basically radiators yes
and how would you deal with that I have
this is the I don't know if I came back
up this is this Nova Nova virus air
purifier technology and they'll treat
they have three different sizes they'll
treat 120 F feet 900 square feet which
is a good size for a classroom or
3,000 and um they've been implemented in
a series of in districts in Texas that
I'm aware of um I don't have pricing for
you but I gave you the link to go and
request that but for for um classrooms
where you you don't have Central systems
you would have to use a technology like
this thank you representative
evil thank you Mr Petty thank you for
being here um as it happens oddly enough
uh when when we had to get the New
Hampshire house back up and running
again after covid we looked at the
ashray standards we looked at mer
filters we looked at filtration system
systems representative creten and I were
on the same committee and we had a lot
to learn about things that we really
didn't know a lot about um I can just in
response partially to what you said the
fix was extremely expensive to get the
building back up and running again um
and some of the machines that you see
around here were things that were our
best solution that we could pay for at
the time we figured out how quickly
could be cleared Etc and I guess um
based on the uh testimony that you've
given um it's very expensive to retrofit
a lot of buildings with the Machinery
that you have uh discussed here and I
just all I'm saying is I know that
because we looked at all these things
and it was very expensive and I'm just
trying to understand your testimony if a
school for for instance or a building
such as ours or whatever was unable to
afford the technology and the
infrastructure that you've described
here are you saying that it would
be rather than um are you saying rather
than requiring masking and social
distancing in a building where you
couldn't afford a lot more fresh air or
filtered air it would be better not to
have masks and not to bother with social
distancing well the answer to the end is
yes the I I I would quibble with the
cost the cost for us to to implement
this technology in 2020 and in a very a
pretty large high school with special
needs students multiple buildings was
$24,000 I mean it it wasn't I mean it
sounds like a lot of money but not in
terms of their operations it wasn't just
just to follow up it depends on I'm
sorry it depends on the facility and you
know uh for one school system 24,000 may
not be enough be a lot and for others it
might be so let's just if we could
assume that it is expensive for a
particular facility to upgrade I I just
wanted to clarify that you think without
the equipment it still is better not to
mask and not to bother social distancing
the the the costs far outweigh the
benefits on
masking um the social distancing with
small particles can't possibly
work um I I really I believe that there
was I don't disagree there was a lack of
knowledge by people trying to do
something to make their erir and their
buildings better I do disagree that this
was going to be an expensive option
because can you imagine instead of all
the silly things we did that if if the
government had offered every resident
through a mechanical contractor
$500 to put a new calgone eyew wave in
their house wouldn't that have been a
lot better solution than what we
did uh representative Penza then
representative
Merchant I do know that um well in New
Hampshire and I think it was everywhere
all across the country that um you know
schools I'm in Rochester got millions of
dollars um directly from the federal
government to provide uh you know
through the cares act to be able to do
things um in schools for example in
summersworth they instead of um using
you know certain protocols they put a
new roof on so I I don't think finances
were a problem here um did you see that
weren't finances weren't an issue across
the country because of cares Z
money um my experience is not unlike
yours I I saw many many situations where
there was considerable covid monies
provided but they weren't
used in a manner that would actually
prevent
covid represent
Merchant thank you madam chair and Mr
Perry thank you for petty for thank you
for being here and taking my question
you're welcome
besides the economics of the equipment
we're talking
about there were many issues we had in
the supply chain we wanted to obtain a
lot of things but our capacity to
manufacture them or to make them
available in a reasonable period of time
was lacking so you my hearing then we
had so much capacity and so much
availability of all these equipment that
we could have done it in a relatively
short period of
time I believe so I mean we never the
the problem with that the problem with
giving you an answer on that is we never
came close to trying to
demand um people install say new calone
ey waves to see what the limit was I
mean we wer even close so I don't know
at what point if if we had 20 million
people demand
that what impact that would have I mean
I obviously I have a a strong business
background but we never really tested
that angle my experience was there to
this day you would have zero problem
going on Amazon and getting a new calone
iway for less than 400
bucks that's but me I concur once we get
through the supply chain issues we had
that today availability on certain
things is available partly because the
demand for things does not exceed our
capacity to make them number two one of
the things in your um presentation I
want say thank you for this is
containment is that correct containment
in in what sense I'm sorry containment
of the virus destruction oh yeah I mean
is that is that a fact I I don't really
want to contain it I either want to
dilute it or I want to destroy it that's
really my goal if I go back to one of
your slides it had containment is one of
the factors of the
three I'm sorry where you at let me see
if I
can if you go back to slide 24 page 24
okay engineering controls it says
destruction dilution and
containment am I misreading
that
construction containment is is where
you're filtering it yes I mean in that
sense so containment is important in the
sense if you're going to as a solution
to it it's important in the sense that
if you were if you had the ability to as
an engineering
control
to isolate the virus and this is what's
being the reason that I say that is
that's what was being done with ebola
right I mean you had very specialized
facilities I think in Oklahoma for those
people coming back from Africa that's
probably on the engineering controls
it's an engineering control but probably
not a pragmatic one for something as
widespread as a
pandemic if I also go back and look on
slide page 33 up in the right hand
corner it says under the
aih on the box to your right it says
preventing as feasible the spread of a
novel pathogen where a motive
transportation is unknowned unknown
requires again OSHA so it's basically
trying
to contain by minimizing transmission
because transmission is a way to
consider containment is that not again
the mask is not so much always to
protect the person wearing it but to
protect the containment or to provide
containment and lack of transmission of
the virus that's what it says here on 33
yeah I was just reading the the
highlighted thing that says that the the
recommendations from CDC for protection
against the pathogen transmitted through
the air are grossly deficient and will
not protect healthcare workers from
aerosol transmission this is where
they're being critical because they're
still using this droplet argument right
which I understand but that's the
protecting the person wearing the mask
versus trying to contain it through the
lack of transmission no no no that that
is that's the source control argument
that you've heard probably right that
argument is completely bogus and the
reason I say that is
um if if you have a particle that had
the The Source control argument is that
if you wear a mask or n95 that that you
if you're sick will stop um transmission
to others
you're the
source but the virus doesn't care
whether it's coming in or going out this
massive
hole so the source control argument was
always bogus it doesn't matter whether
you're the one that's sick or the person
on the outside's sick that mask is not
going to stop that virus going One
Direction or the other it's not a
one-way
mask so it might hearing then in the O
we shouldn't have surgeons wearing a
mask that's for a different purpose
that's for these huge droplets and this
is this is as I said earlier this is for
these huge droplets and uh
spum uh the literature is absolutely
clear that that the surgical Mass are
for those large droplets but not for
aerosols and that there's been no
study uh that shown that wearing a
surgical mask protects either the
surgeon or the patient from infectious
diseases those are aerosols those are
little guys so so that that is the
confusion to be candid as an exposure
expert that lies out there is people do
see Physicians wearing masks and they
think well they they're doing some good
they're doing some good with respect to
these large the big guys the droplets
but they're not doing any good with
respect to the little guys
aerosols yes ma'am repres creation thank
you uh thank you for taking my question
again
so I I've not seen any study that said
that an n95 would not reduce the dose
that's transmitted by a person who's
infected
to the rain study just came out
that's the kind of like
the it's it's the meta analysis of the
RCT so it's it says that
explicitly it says that in real world
situations it's unclear if it reduces
transmission or not but in terms of
reducing the actual dose that's
being the the difficulty is that
[Music]
um the particles are so small and the
gaps are relatively so large that that
physically just can't
happen it's like trying to stop a BB
with a soccer net do you randomly have
one hit the mesh once in a while I guess
but and then beyond that you
have you have the world of the gaps on
the
outside which overwhelm everything in
other words I say to Everybody Let's
imagine you have
smoke uh in a
[Music]
room and uh you're waiting for it to to
come through the wall but then you have
a window that's open but where is it
going to go it always goes to the pathol
Le resistance so it's of course going to
come right out the window if you have
big gaps that's where all the stuff's
moving back and forth either coming in
or going out um like I said the source
control arguments always been Bogus the
the virus isn't if you got a super
freeway it's not going to be able to go
one way through it and then the other
way it can't I mean that's just silly I
don't know where that came from the
source control argument to me has always
been
bogus uh represent
licas so
when when we have like the pyramid or
yeah the inverted pyramid the hierarchy
of controls right and containment is in
there that inverted pyramid is a general
for all things for all hazards it could
be for silica or anything else yes right
so containment may be more appropriate
for
some issues than for you know for some
contaminants than for others is that
yeah and and containment would be approp
more appropriate for Co if it had a
lethality of
50% I mean you wouldn't want to allow
like Ebola you
don't you you want to isolate everything
and everyone because the consequences
are so dire as I said before one of the
problems with MKS are that The lethality
of covid thank God was so low overall
still a lot of people
died that people really didn't know
whether it was doing any good or not now
you would know for sure if one out of
two people wearing something didn't
work how would you do containment then
for an an
Airborne virus or other contaminant how
well for an Airborne virus how would you
do containment I don't think you can in
general the only way you can do
containment is it is very early
on like like the Ebola cases where you
try to isolate just a hand of people
sick but once it's a pandemic it's by
definition not
contained okay thank you um you're
welcome Mr Petty um coming from an
agricultural background when I look at
containment I look at a spill um as
being contained and I understand that
there's other containments um but I
think you mentioned earlier that the n95
cannot be used for asbest is that
correct yeah it's it's legally not
allowed for example in the state of
California no is as Festus larger or
smaller in microns than the covid virus
on average about 50 times larger thank
you uh representative Belcher and then
representative penzer and then we're
going to wrap it up we have another I've
got just two quick ones they shouldn't
take too long um first one is because we
mentioned and I've had this experience
as well with my h house water filter
with
UVC whatever reason there doesn't seem
to be a high availability of LED UVC
technology is there you have any reason
for that and is that something that we
could in a report perhaps appeal to the
private sector to work
toward I think the issue there has to do
with wavelength because obviously the
UVC is at the thing that's destructive
is the wavelength and I don't think LEDs
have the right
wavelength that's good to know and uh
one more quick one we received testimony
regarding uh the methods that we tried
here in New Hampshire it was described
um in its totality this includes masking
and all the other things as well as
social distancing that were used it was
described as the Swiss cheese method I
guess the idea being that you're just
layering these layers of Swiss cheese on
top of each other till there's no holes
left is the analogy um do you think such
a method of trying to approach this was
a make doesn't make sense B do you think
it was reasonable and best practice and
C is there any reason to believe believe
that it actually
worked I think there was a
desire by the public to try to help
understandably so I think people in
political leadership positions offered a
inexpensive solution that had no chance
of working and in
fact uh move the ball away from things
that would have worked and that was if
you can imagine the amount of time and
energy associated with masking and all
this and putting all these little dots
in in stores what if we' had up at I can
guarantee it wouldn't have cost as much
money as putting new Calgon eye waves in
their HVAC
systems so the answer is that we got
distracted by non-science Solutions
frankly and that I mean appreciate I
work on the most liberal side of the
world toxic
Tor I've I've worked I work on all the
big cases I'm the expert on all almost
all the big cases if I thought for two
seconds that this was th this was of
concern to my clients that I was out
there speaking out and I said I haven't
changed I've always been about
protecting workers in the public this
doesn't do that I have an obligation
giving my credentials and background to
say something and I did and I did it all
all pro
bono to the tune of hundreds of
thousands of dollars which is fine I I
have his favorite phrase I say to people
all the time I said at the end of the
day it says under your Tombstone born
and died the question is did you do any
good in
between now I'm I also say that I'm
probably not up for sainthood I think
Earth purgatory and I'm due for return
visit I just hope I don't have to go to
school
again representative Penza and then
representative Eble and then we will
close this
hearing so I'm not sure if you remember
but I met you um when I was in a rep so
and we talked okay so my husband um
works for the the largest um HVAC
Plumbing all of that in um in the
Northeast they're in nine states and I
just wanted to speak to some of the
equipment that I had showed you that he
had sent to the school that my kids were
at um was in your repertoire at the time
correct correct do you remember that
okay so um and at the time I just wanted
to speak to this because I think it's
important there was no problem at all
with Supply um we didn't have there
wasn't a huge demand on it and at that
time FW web which I know I told you said
that they could probably Supply almost
every single school in the state with
this equipment to help whether they had
a newer school and could put it directly
into the ventilation system system or if
it was classroom specific like what is
here right now yeah my my comment
earlier was I mean the hpac industry is
massive in fact ashray their meeting is
the largest meeting of any organization
in the United States is my understanding
there it's a huge business um and so I
think it was never
tapped um the only reason I was being
balanced about my response to the other
rep
was we you know some point you do have a
supply and demand issue I don't know
where that is but we never came close to
it that's the problem so I was just
trying to be honest about at some point
you would see a point where perhaps
there would be an issue I don't know but
we never came even close to that and
it's a huge huge
business represent Vil and thank you
madam chair there was one more question
yeah oh I'm sorry um I was just GNA ask
um going back to the studies that you
discussed earlier were and the effects
of masks versus
covid were there other factors
considered in those studies or were they
just look looking at uh the effect of
masking because it's very difficult with
studies the whole issue of control and
you know other things that were going on
with the people that were masking sure
um the key is to have well-designed
rcts uh that's what you want to look at
where you try to control it's impossible
to control everything but you try to
control as best you can to a single
change in parameter with a similar
population the the problem was that CDC
started supporting masking uh by studies
oftentimes they were funding that were
observational which is if you look at
the PID of of studies under epidemiology
observational are much lower than say
rcts
and I I felt strongly so what I did is I
started going because I had to go
through them in court cases right and
there were like 50 of them so I would go
through each study and I would critique
them and show them where they were they
were co-founders or they were
fundamental problems with their
statistics or whatever I had a years
where The Graduate level statistics and
then I felt strongly enough about it
that I put together some podcasts I
think four or five of them where I went
through all of those not I don't know if
they're all but most of the CDC studies
on where the flaws were and I put them
up on YouTube and rumble or something
just to get that information out there
as to to why these studies these
observational studies were really had
issues I'm not the first one to say that
um it's pretty well established science
that you want to move towards rcts
mainly in in almost all Dimensions
because you want to you want to limit
the co-founders as much as you can the
things that would also impact the
results and you want to have two groups
uh ideally blinded where one group has
is given the drug or is given the
masking and the other group isn't and
it's a little hard to Blind that but um
The Hope is then then you can see the
difference and there aren't co-founders
impacting the
results uh ma'am last
question please thank you for indulging
me I'll try to keep it brief um I guess
just thinking back to the early days of
the pandemic when it wasn't like fully
clear whether it was droplet spread or
or Airborne spread um I gu do you have
any hypotheses as to why it kind of took
us so long to get to that idea that it
was airborne and that air quality would
be a better way to go and thinking about
you know oh we never got you know even
close to having supply chain issues with
with a quality and things why do you
think that was and what do you think
that we could do to avoid that in the
future or sort of jump toward this
because I agree that that the sort of
industrial controls is is a much better
way to go than relying on you know
individuals to to figure out mask fit
and how many people they can have in a
room and that sort of thing well having
done this for 45 years I I will be blunt
I usually am in front of juries that's
science was well known for decades we
were lied to we were lied to about the
fact that the issue was droplets we
still are being lied to and that's why
you have two major I mean it takes time
to write a 28-page letter to CDC and get
get it reviewed by six other scientists
and and the one before me the year
before me I wasn't involved in that did
the same thing saying look go back and
read them we're
saying this is not an issue of rets this
is an issue of
aerosols it's a virus we know this I
mean yeah are there differences between
a flu virus and a covid virus a little
bit but in terms of particle sizes and a
lot of the ways we deal with them no not
really so um so that the bottom line is
I guess I hate to be that strong but
we're basically being lied
to okay thank you everyone uh thank you
m to Petty uh for coming um really
appreciate it very informative um
answers a lot of my
questions
um so again thank you so much um if you
could email me this presentation I would
uh I would love to email it out to the
committee members I know we have a hard
copy here but sometimes uh and if you
could also put in that uh some of where
we could go look at some of your
podcasts um so if anyone has more
questions they can review those I'd
really appreciate that just go to Petty
podcast on rumble or YouTube um I will
send you a PDF of it and thank you very
much to all members of the committee and
to you chairman for the opportunity and
um best of wishes and making good
decisions thank you and we'll close out
this hearing um and while Mr Petty uh
closes up why don't we take a uh three
minute break and
return Yes we have another
speaker have Dr called off
here
e
if members can take their seats we'll
get
started I'd like to thank Dr uh cuor
from coming up uh to speak with us today
and um as you can see he's a former
professor of medicine from Harvard and
I'll let him introduce his credentials
also
uh ple please turn on your microphone
thank you thank you so much for having
me and I'm a a bio statistician and uh
infectious disease
ecologist I used to be a professor at of
medicine at Harvard for first Associated
and then full for about 20 years until
they didn't want me
anymore um and I was kind of shocked
when the pandemic come came because I'm
an infectious disease technologist and
basically all the principles of Public
Health were thrown out the
window so I'm going to talk about
specifically is um yeah first that's a
background about covid and age and then
talk about the two sort of
approaches uh that were used the
lockdowns versus the focus
protection and then I'm going to talk
about some of the collateral Public
Health damage a little bit about
education also uh but I'm a public
health person and then some comparison
about different places and then a little
bit about social
inequalities um and uh if you have any
specific questions just interrupt me and
I think we'll have a question Q&A
session at the end
also uh
so when the co uh when I heard first
about the covid and there was these
outbreaks in Northern Italy and which
was the first places outside of
China um I was kind of scared for about
10 20 minutes um because I went to look
at the data from vuhan at at this time
there was no death I think in the US so
I looked at the mortality in the vuhan
and obviously everybody would be exposed
but uh there's a I looked at the age of
the people who died in vuhan and there
was mostly older people so I did a a
little calculation to see we didn't know
then the the the absolute magnitud of
the risk but I could look at the
relative risk different age group and it
was clear that there were more than a
thousandfold difference in mortality
risk between the oldest and the youngest
people so that's very important to know
when you decide what to do about it
because it basically means we have to do
a really good job protecting all the
people because they at high risk but we
don't have to worry about uh the kids so
the reason I was only afraid for 10 20
minutes was because I have three kids uh
as as every parent I'm much more
concerned about my children than myself
so I knew that they were going to be
fine I didn't have to worry about
them uh so here are the later on we do
more about what the infection fatality
rate is and we can see that uh for
example uh if you are a a woman 80 plus
with no underlying condition you have
about a 1% risk of dying from covid
on the other
hand and you have a 99% chance of
surviving on the other hand if you are a
girl uh age0 to uh 19 your probability
of surviving Co is
99.9999 6% which is almost
100 so you can see here also the
enormous gradient in ag and that was
something that was forgotten during the
pandemic but we sort of ignored it as so
just pretending that everybody was at
risk and we have to treat everybody the
same in terms of
protection so uh in most of the world uh
lockdowns were
implemented and
lockdowns have many components and there
was variation of course in different
places but schools and universities were
closed for so was online
learning uh no extracurricular
activities for kids playing soccer or
baseball or dance class or so on
businesses were closed uh restaurants
were
closed uh a lot of people were told to
work from
home uh in some places and cases people
were told to stay at home stay indoors
at home and we learned from the previous
speak that that wasn't the smartest
thing to do uh we closed Parks
playgrounds and
beaches uh I think uh also based on the
previous I mean Outdoors is the safest
place to be because Z win so I would say
there's probably not a during the
pandemic the safest Pro place to be was
probably on the top of Mount Washington
because there's so which wi there
that uh they were vaccine passports so
if people didn't have vaccines they w't
allowed to do things there were travel
restrictions both internationally but
also between
states um no inperson religious services
or cultural
activities social and physical distance
Ing and cancel medical
appointments and and care so there's a
whole range of these uh lockdowns that
were
implemented Focus protection the
argument was that we should do
everything we can to protect older
people because they're the one at high
risk we should let children go to school
and enjoy their friends have a social
life and young and middle AG adults may
live near normal lives uh to minimize
the collateral damage from the pandemic
meas from the
lockdowns so uh how to protect the old
well one is to prioritize the old for
vaccinations both within countries and
between
countries uh using people who have
recovered from Co because they have
natural immunity or vaccine acquired
immunity to use them to staff uh nursing
homes and other places where older very
frail people live they are the least
likely to infect them minimize staff
rotation in nursing homes let older
people work from home uh and if possible
offer them some pay temporary sabatical
during Peak transmission maybe using
Social Security funds or something
minimize multigenerational living with
temporary housing let students be be at
the universities where they if they get
infected they will infect other young
people instead of infecting their older
parents or
grandparents uh home delivery of food
and Necessities as to old people meet
Outdoors instead of indoors and Etc so
there's a long list of things one can do
to protect all the people some of those
things were done but I would say most of
them were not actually
implemented so in 20120 together with uh
uh Dr J Baya from Stanford and Dr sonat
Gupta from Oxford who is the preeminent
infection to Technologies in the world
uh we we wrote a grand PR iteration to
argue for Focus protection and uh it
receiv received a lot of attention a lot
of people signed it including uh
scientists and healthcare workers but it
also received a lot of uh push back from
the uh sort of established uh uh
establishment
so so what does Lockdown do well
lockdowns can postpone things because if
you don't meet people then there is less
transmission so you do reduce the the
amount of Transmissions you can postpone
things but that means you're dragging
out for longer because you cannot
prevent this from spreading it was clear
very ear on to any competent infectious
disease apologist that it hit Northern
Italy and Iran it did it in a of a
stealth manner it uh we didn't know who
brought it into Italy for example and it
was circulating for quite some time
before we know there was anything going
on so it was sort of Brewing under the
surface and then it exploded so so just
like influenza it is impossible it was
impossible to do it so it was very clear
in early
2020 that is will spread to the whole
world sooner or
later um
so lockdowns doesn't prevent that it can
postpone things and New Zealand was the
most successful at postponing thing
because they an island they were in the
southern hemisphere so they could sort
of completely isolate themselves uh so
what is the good with this thing well
it's good to flatten the curve to
prevent Health Care overload we don't
want everybody to be uh sick at the same
time but primarily what is important
there is ex actually to protect also the
older people because they are the one
who will go to the hospital if they get
infected so so uh so that flattens the
curve also the bad thing it actually
makes it harder to protect older
highrisk people people because you have
to protect them for a longer time time
period until the pandemic is
over uh and of course the longer
lockdown the more collateral damage
there is and we're seeing um we're
seeing now the the huge effect of the
collateral damage because while covid is
very much there that week people are
getting sick or that month a lot of the
collateral damage much is long-term
rather than shortterm and that's one of
the principles of Public Health the two
principle is you can't just worry about
one disease you have to worry about all
public health you can't just worry about
Co you also have to concern about cancer
cardiovascular disease and mental health
the other thing you can't just look at
shortterm you have to look at the
long-term consequences so we had Mis
cancer screening and treatments worst
cardiovascular disease outcomes skip
diabetics diabetic appointments
plummeting childhood vaccination rates
deteriorating Mental Health malnutrition
and starvation in the developing world
uh so this was a complete disaster um
and I just going to give you there's
enormous amount of studies now showing
this collateral damage on public health
I'm just going to show a few example
here's
cancer uh this is from the spring of
202 so uh the Baseline is for example if
you look at the left there there were
over 2,000 for breast cancer newly
identified patient per week and a month
later it was only about a
thousand that's not because Co prevents
cancer is because the cancer is there
but it's not detecting there the reason
we want to know if somebody has cancer
because you can start a
treatment so Health Care is actually a
good thing we need to people to get the
health care so if you don't even detect
the cancer they not getting getting it
now they're not going to die in 2020
from breast cancer probably not in 202
or 22 or 23 either but
somebody who uh who
might might not die two or three years
from now instead of living another 20
years so this is consequences that we
are not living with can I ask a question
yeah hi yes on on this slide and the
previous slide what is the point because
we know that we know that everything was
overwhelmed and so we know that other
things were missed so are you ascribe
being it's someone's fault like can you
explain further yeah so it wasn't
actually that the hospitals were
overwhelmed because a lot of hospitals
were empty and a lot of hosp during the
covid uh so some hospitals overwhelmed
like in New York for example in the
spring of 2020 they were quite
overwhelmed in New York City but uh in
other places of the country the the the
virus hadn't arrived yet so the
hospitals were actually close to empty
in many places because they didn't have
covid patients but the patient did not
go to their regular screening activities
they didn't go to if they have if they
had a heart problem they stayed home and
many died at home instead of actually
going to the hospitals to get the proper
care so this is effect not on the fact
that there was a lot of covid is in the
is from the fact that people didn't seek
the health care they were afraid to go
to the hospitals or in some cases things
was postponed like for example the
dental care tended to be they close the
offices they postpone the dental care
the dental care doesn't take care of any
covid patients so has nothing to do with
Co it was just part of the lockdown that
they closed things down so these
lockdowns that was that was due because
of the covid they lock down but they did
it was not necessary to look down so for
example Sweden did not look down his
healthc care
system uh uh and we will get back to
Sweden but that's a very good question
so thank
you
um here we can see us cancer incidents
2018 to 2020 so it goes a little bit up
and down like a random variation from
2018 um and so on and then suddenly in
2020 it plummets and again that's not
because people didn't have cancer it
wasn't detected and you would hope that
then would sort of be a corresponding
going above to sort of catch all those
things that's were where we missed but
while it does Rebound it's still Below
in is still below what you would have
expected so there was no proper rebound
uh it was worse in
2020 but uh it uh early 2020 but uh it
never really sort of we never catched up
with finding those those
cancers and here's just one graph of us
cancer
mortality uh from 2010 to 2022 so we see
there was like a lower downward Trend
and then in 2020 sort of wasn't much
difference from what you would expect
but then in 2021 and 22 it's sort of
going up uh so that downward trend has
been broken and now is it then going up
slightly and I would expect this to
continue because most of these cancer
cases that we missed the mortality is
years in advance but uh not just you
wouldn't expect them to see only in a
few years most of them will be much
later that you see this excess excess
death
uh here's an example of
diabetes um so the Baseline is 100% And
then we see that it it in
the
uh the the diabetes test isort of going
down so we not getting proper care for
diabetes
patients uh vaccinations
plummeted uh and childhood vaccinations
are very important we're now seeing that
there like nil outbreaks which uh they
has been before but they are more of
that than it used to be so uh we have
worldwide that uh there were less
vaccinations and that was the dip it
came back a little bit but it's not back
to where it should be so that's another
very problem from these lockdowns
measures uh mental health
uh
uh if you look at the the colum to the
second to the right seriously considered
suicide in past 30 days
among people aged 18 to 24 it was
25% in June of 2020 so there was there
was enormous Med uh mental health
consequences of uh of these
lockdowns uh thank you for bringing that
up uh Dr kov um just a statement and a
question um because I just happened to
be on an intergovermental White House
call uh in the spring of 2020
where they were already discussing the
effects that the lockdowns were going to
have uh with increased um suicides
increased uh addiction rates and
increased abuse
um and having knowing that is there
anything I know you're you're talking
about preventive measures but do you
think it would have been the
responsibility of the government
as um at that time knowing that this was
going to occur to try and offset how
that would be and in in your
professional opinion I think you're
talking to how some of that could have
been averted but there is anything else
possibly and maybe you'll get to it
later on in your presentation that we
could have done um it was just I just
happened to be on the call and to know
that the White House at that time was
already talking about this early on in
the pandemic was really concerning to me
yes you're right there was also a
problem with like alcoholism and opio
overdoses um and I think that the social
support netor collapsed with the
lockdowns people didn't go to meet their
friends uh they didn't go to school or
universities they uh there was the
religious Services was not available and
a lot of people that's a big social
support network but also cultural
activities where you meet meet people so
in all sectors of society there are
these social Gathering points that are
not just for pleasure it's also for
mental support so uh and I think mental
health is is as serious as physical
health so I think both of them are
important uh this is actually from the
UK but they did some U they looked at
students uh preparing pre and during
pandemic so the stress level was uh both
were very similar for for uh uh men and
women students but uh a little uh more
stress more sleep problems worse diet
and less physical activity so those are
all basics for for uh General Health but
also not only for General Health because
we know exercise good diet is good to
avoid cancer for example but it's also
good to fight infections so to being
outside and exercising and eating
healthy is actually good to uh be able
to then deal with an infection whether
it's co or influenza or something
else uh one of the most tragic I think
is uh is what happened in the developing
world who sort of cop copied what the US
and Western Europe did and uh uh there
were starvation and uh and malnutrition
and for example in India the people the
poor people they live on the street they
sell their they sell their food on the
streets and then they make money and
they buy for to sell the next day and
then they have a little bit to eat
themselves that ended so you had all
these very poor people who had to walk
home several days to their Villages and
some of them died on that track home so
uh and there were examples from Africa
where where uh the markets closed and
then the the families couldn't feed
their kids anymore so this is one of the
most tragic
things uh leaving Public Health we have
education which well education is also
good important for for public health
because we know that good education
leads leads to healthier lives
throughout throughout uh throughout life
and we can see here that uh in this is
New Hampshire the mass course in there
were no testing in
2020 uh but the 2021 the math course
were went way
down and it has recovered a little bit
since then which is good uh very
important but it's not back to what it
used to
be uh the the English test scord they
didn't decrease as much but we haven't
seen the rebound either so they also
less than it used to
be so let me compare then a little bit
with Mo because most St B in the US had
lockdowns to larger or smaller
degrees and um the same in countries
Canada had a very strong lockdowns and
most European countries so there were
sort of a few places that stood up one
stood out one was Sweden they didn't
close the schools for kids age 1 to 15
they didn't lock down businesses a
restaurants so it was a fairly normal
life they did take measures to protect
older people a variety of measures but
Sweden was heavily criticized
2020 to uh uh because of U uh because of
uh because they didn't do that and it
was also that they were going to a lot
of people are going to kill and they
would sometimes you would think there
would be no seds left and I should say
here that my native country is Sweden so
I was following Sweden very
closely um I also participated in the
discussions uh supporting the Swedish
approach in that spring because I was
afraid that they will Buckle under the
international pressure
uh Florida was an exception in the US in
the spring of 2020 they did like
everybody else they closed the schools
and stuff but then there was a shift uh
I think in the summer of 2020 so they
made sure the schools were opened and
they tried to do Focus protection
instead of Lock lockdowns and another
one was South Dakota I don't know how
much Focus protection they did but they
didn't lock down
much um
so we can then sort of see now
it's four years later we can see what
happens
happened so first of all for spring of
2020 when uh the 1.8 million children in
Sweden ages 1 to 15 they were all in
school no masks no social distancing in
the classrooms If the child was sick
they were told to stay home there were
no testing for covid but if they were
sick whether it was covid or whatever
they were told to stay home which I
think is actually quite a good thing to
to do um there were during the Spring
there was Zero covid death among
children and only a few
hospitalizations and teachers had the
same Co risk as the average of other
professions uh so we knew and we knew
that the Swedish public health agency
published a report in early July of 2020
where they presented
this uh so it was clear already then
that
keeping schools open was not dangerous
at all there was no Co reason to do it
uh and of course education is important
for children uh Sweden did not have any
learning loss they had done this testing
so unlike US states there was no
learning loss in
Sweden uh if you compare excess
death uh and covid death by country This
Is 2020 to 2022 of three
years um we can see
that um Sweden it so the right side are
the Coes the the red ones and you can
see that Sweden is not the lowest but
it's on the lower half of it it is lower
than the
average uh New Zealand is the the very
lowest um because they really sort of
contained it and they sort of not
completely but they managed to keep keep
it out out for a few
years uh if we like look at access
deaths so that is actually the more
important measure because one thing you
can covid death you can Define in
different ways so there can be VAR with
that but a death is a death uh so
countries can't really fetch the
numbers um and also it's what's most
important because it combines the
mortality due
to covid but also mortality due to for
example cardiovascular disease because
of the lockdown so it sort of gives the
whole picture
only for those three years so it doesn't
count the cancer death that we'll
have in the next few years but at least
it does it for those three years and we
can see that Sweden did is the lowest
here uh Norway and Denmark were the
second lowest and they also they did
some school closings but they had took a
lighter touch on the lockdowns than most
European
countries uh the US did not do so well
uh neither in terms of covid nor in
terms of the uh total exess death
we're going to look at the different
states in the US and uh yeah go ahead
represent EV yeah thank you thank you
doctor so I just see this line here it
says also for vaccines so I I don't know
what that means but I was I was curious
about the vaccine vaccination rates in
the in these different countries and how
you analyze that and that factors in
yeah so Focus Focus protection is to
protect the older people like nursing
home and stuff but you also had Focus
protections when the vaccine came so the
question was who do you vaccinate first
and Sweden was actually quite brutal
they decided uh well healthcare workers
should have it but then it was very
strict by age so there was even a guy he
was uh the administrator at some health
care place and uh he didn't see patients
he decided to get it himself uh sort of
out of order because he wasn't that old
but he was fired because he wasn't
supposed to get the vaccine that was
needed for the older people so Sweden
was very strict of having a very
age-based high risk
first um if uh and
uh and that could be sort of ConEd to
CDC when they came out with a
recommendation they they recommended
healthcare worker which is good uh but
they uh recommended
certain uh uh sort of everyday workers
uh to get as like store clerks and what
they consider high-risk groups to get it
before the older people and I think that
was a huge
mistake and Florida didn't follow it
Florida followed re rejected CDC
guidelines and just went with the age
instead and then eventually Most states
actually sort of reversed it and they
went to more age-based
approach
but uh I was sort of discouraged when I
in in 202 21 early I saw like students
bragging about oh I got the vaccine they
were like 20 in their 20s and then my 87
year old neighbor she hadn't gotten it
yet so that wasn't right and they
mandated vaccines for students and young
people but there was no mandate for the
retired people so there was a lot of old
people in the US who didn't get the
vaccine in a timely manner what a lot of
younger people did so Focus protection
was also about the vaccines thank you
may may I just ask a quick question
just us this will later when we're figur
out um can you say which um vaccines
were utilized in Sweden and also the
other uh countries you listed as being
low here uh so Sweden actually had a
very high vaccination rate and they used
fiser modna and astrazenica which is
different from the US which used fiser
modna and Johnson and Johnson astroica
was not never approved in the
US
and that actually a good question
because that could uh make a difference
so uh but one reason that Sweden is very
very uh did well was because of this uh
vaccinations and focusing on the older
people to get vac
vaccinated
uh so this is another exess death in
Europe uh where Sweden is the lowest now
when we look at exess deaths you can
calculate a little bit different ways
what typically you do for Access death
is you look at the total death in 2020
and 22 and then you compare it what
would it been if were the same rate in
the prior three years like
201 uh 17 18 and 19 but you can also
select a prior five years for example or
you can start to put a little bit of a
trend line so depending on what methods
you use the exact numbers are going to
vary a little bit and the exact order
will vary a little bit but the basic
picture is the same uh so I think
there's some models you use Norway will
actually be slightly better than Sweden
so uh but this particular uh one Sweden
was the lowest and Bulgaria was the
worst uh UK is not and us are not in
this graph but UK had 10% and US
14% so us was by far the worst but also
by far the
best uh I think repres thank you mam
chair um back to the previous slide if I
may so that's the death rates um is the
vaccination rates there as well so is
the mortality rate so is there slides
later on to talk about the vaccination
rate compared to the death rate I have
no slide for that now you don't thank I
could talk about about vaccines because
they work with vaccines but I haven't uh
I have I I I think that that wasn't my
request to do that
so uh this is just all cost morality in
Sweden through many years and you can
see
that
um it would have been going down 2018
and 19 That season was very low 201920
it went a little bit up and then it went
down but there's not a major excess here
and ter of all cross morality for Sweden
because of the
pandemic uh now when we do all excess
death we compare some years now between
previous years so it's not critical to
adjust for age you can do it but it has
minimal effect because you actually
comparing a very similar H distribution
in one country to like a few years below
before but if you compare covid rates
you should have you have to adjust for
for
mortality uh Maine is the oldest state
in the
has the oldest population in the US so
obviously that's because people are
older they will die more that's an
unfortunate fact of
life uh so if you compare cancer rates
for example you always adjust for age no
sane epiology would ever compare cancer
rat without adjusting for
AG with Co you also have to adjust for
age because Co is much more common in
older
people and we don't want to know that if
you compare Maine and New Hampshire well
if there are more cases in Co in Maine
than in New Hampshire maybe that's
because they're older that's not what we
want to compare we want to adjust it for
the age so it's very important to adjust
for age in Co that wasn't always done so
when you when you see comparison of Co
Race by state for example you have to
make sure that they're age adjusted I
just going to give an example so I'm
going into a little bit of mathematics
here uh so uh if you look at crude
annual mortality race comparing Nigeria
with
Japan and we all know that Japan is a
very wealthy country and Nigeria less so
so you would expect that people died
more in Nigeria than in Japan but if you
look at the just the crude annual
mortality
rates actually there are more people
dying in Japan than Nigeria why is that
uh represent mer thank you madam chair
this is interesting
because some data I saw looking at State
comparisons between new h and other
states New Hampshire actually ranked
probably second from the bottom as far
as death rates so using the analogy
we're talking about here given the fact
New Hampshire is probably be the second
oldest state in the country and they had
the lowest death rate would that not be
something it doesn't jive and trying to
get to is you expect New Hampshire with
a higher elderly population would have a
higher crude mortality rate in reality
in covid we actually had less yep that's
true
so New Hampshire did well thank you and
Maine did well
too thank
you uh so the thing is the age
distribution so Nigeria has a very young
population and young people don't die
Japan has a very old uh population and
old people tend to die so if we compare
every age group in every age group
mortality is higher in Nigeria among
kids 25 versus 6 among children 5 15 2.1
versus 0.1 among people over 70 55
versus 44 so in every age group Japanese
people are less likely to die but if you
add them up without adjusting for age
Nigeria comes out looking great so it is
important always when you look at this
Co rates or cancer rates to always
adjust for age and in the US actually
there's quite big difference in average
age it's I think between Maine and Texas
the the average age is 10 year
difference and that's quite a bit if it
was only one year it wouldn't make much
difference but it is quite a lot I'm
going to skip that one so here's the co
mortality between the 12 largest states
in the country so we know Texas didn't
do very
well uh uh Ohio Georgia a little bit
better but not so much Michigan and
Pennsylvania close to the national
average uh the best of these 12 states
were Florida and Virginia and uh and
also California California was the heavy
lockdown state Florida was the least one
of the least lockdown
States so uh clearly when Flor didn't Lo
down there's no evidence here that that
made it bad in Florida Florida came out
very well looking at these states now
there are many other factors other than
lockdowns and focus protected they play
a role here but at least we can sort of
say that Florida ended up really really
bad because they didn't lock down they
did quite
well uh if you compare the Dakotas South
Dakota didn't lock down North Dakota did
South Dakota plus three North Dakota
minus 2 they are basically all very
close to the national average not a not
a big
difference and I think that's sort of uh
the message here lockdown doesn't help
when it comes to covid it doesn't harm
when it comes to covid mortality either
it's sort of a wash
uh it does harm when it comes to
Collateral Damage the
lockdowns uh thank you represent gr go
ahead thank you you're really only
basing that comment on that one data
point so what other things that could
have interplayed with that to affect
that because that's not really I can
understand why you're saying that if
lockdown were the only issue but were
there other things that those states
were doing at the same time that could
have that's doesn't really to me
comparing one data point and using that
as a basis doesn't
really Jive you know what I mean yeah so
there could be you're right there could
be very other things so maybe uh nor
maybe South Dakota did something else
that really lowered the maybe they have
better Healthcare or something like that
so my only Point here is that looking at
this data where there a lot of factors
influencing it there's no evidence that
the the states who didn't lock down that
they did any worse than others when it
comes to co mortality uh represent Penza
yeah so I'm very familiar with um so it
was early on in in 2020 um when the
schools closed down U and I watched very
closely about what happened in Sweden um
shared that a lot of that information I
I can grab old emails I'm sure so I
think that the most significant thing
and I don't know where that slide is um
is specifically about the schools
because that is um you know kind of
comparing Apples to Apples ones that you
know without having masks and all that
if you're you know if you're sick stay
home so could you focus on that just for
a little bit um you know in comparing
that maybe to someone else that did all
of those types of
things yeah so I think there's also been
studies showing that there's no evidence
that closing schools reduced
Transmission in the general general
population and
that's different from in many ways Co is
similar to influenza but that's actually
one where it's different from influenza
because
influenza kids are super
spreaders if if you have kids you
probably know that they are good as
spreading
viruses uh so for
influenza
uh they are super spreaders so if so for
example vaccinating kids will sort of
reduce that spread in the through the
school so schools are sort of a super SP
for K that was not the case there was
early on there was a study from Iceland
that showed that um uh and and they have
a small sort of population and they can
look at the genetics of the virus so
they can kind of figure out who infected
who and they found that adults will
often infect kids but kids will very
rarely infect adults so that's something
we knew in 2020 so that sort of goes
together I I presented the Swedish data
that none of the Went to went to U uh
die from covid and very few station and
the teachers had the same risk as the
average of other professions so that's
sort of epidemiological
data um the I that sort of combines with
the Iceland data that sort of explains
what we saw in Sweden so those are
different different types of of
information we have but they sort of
confirm each
other presentative belter thank you
madam chair uh and this is really good
information um one thing i' I'd like to
get into just to make sure I have the
correct idea of what's going on
regarding what we're looking at as far
as these mortality
statistics one of the things I think
we're going to be looking at as a
committee um I have a lot of personal
interest in um is the uh the sort of
differences we see between um mortality
caused by covid versus all cause
mortality and one of the things that I'm
I have some concern about and I'm
certainly open to the possibility that
I'm wrong but I have seen that there
were um more than one possible Financial
incentives that could have I'm not
saying they definitely did but they
could have contributed to over diagnosis
of covid and or over listing of covid
deaths um so looking at this is this
data we're seeing right now this is
based on those who were listed as covid
deaths and does that sort of jive with
the overall context of um all cause
mortality that we saw at the
time your speaker please sorry thank you
all cost mortality is easy because
people are dead or not uh uh Co
mortality is defined different in
different places so for example in the
European countries they are different
definitions of it so you can't complete
complely compare those
numbers uh in the US there could also be
Regional
differences but we know that
uh there has been sort of studies where
you look at the actual medical records
of people so we know that some people
there sort of three groups there are
those who died because of co co was the
underlaying cause of death there's also
those who where was a contributing cost
they might be sick for other reasons but
then K was sort of contributing as
together with these other ones and thr
tip to balance and then there are those
where it was not Rel to covid uh there
are examples of people who maybe died in
the car accident but they had tested
positive for covid a week before and
they classified as a covid death so they
all these three
groups uh so that makes covid mortality
sort of a little bit fussy so I don't
know if South Dakota North Dakota had
different definition I would expect them
to be very similar but I don't know for
sure so that's one possible explanation
for for these and you're also right
there was sort of incentives for
Hospital there were there were Financial
incentives both in the US as well as in
some countries in Europe of of
diagnosing a covid death either because
the hospitals got extra sort of bonus
pays there was
also funeral uh expenses that states
were giving to families if it was a if
was a covid death so that sort of gave
an incentives to to to make it
covid um and most people wouldn't likee
completely but if Co was sort of maybe
or maybe not you could sort of tip the
balance yeah there a lot of intri
intricacies between these data so it's
really good that you are sort of on top
of
that uh so here's the good news Co
mortality in New England was quite
good uh all the New England states were
below average and New Hampshire was way
below the US
average
uh and here I want to illustrate and
this is sort of a little bit hard to see
I illustrate the importance of age
adjustments so in the left is the raw
rates on the right or the age adjusted
rate so you see Texas for example the
raw rate is about the national
average but if you age adjust is one of
the worst one of the five worst because
Texas is a very young population you can
compare that with Pennsylvania which has
a fairly old
population uh the raw rate is 17% above
the national average but uh the age
adjusted is 2% so the one to the right
here so are the correct numbers and you
can see how it can sort of shift up or
down quite a
lot
um New Hampshire is minus 35 in the Raw
rates but then if you adjust for age
it's minus 41 so that's because New
Hampshire has an older population than
the US average therefore it sort of
looks better when you age adjust so for
some states it goes down and for some
states it goes
up and this is excess mortality by state
and age so to the left we have excess
mortality in 2022 23 and the winner
is can you read
Vermont the winner is New
Hampshire and the worst one
is Arizona and I'm sorry that this is so
small uh Arizona was the
worst uh so to the left is all
ages uh the second panel is 65 plus then
it's 45 to 64 and the right one is 15 to
and we can the the green is Florida the
which was sort of a non- lockdown State
the orange or the yellow is California
which was a very harsh lockdown state
they're sort of similar in the sense
they have both a warm nice climate and
we can see that uh California did not do
well and especially among the younger
people it didn't do
well um and I think lockdown sort of
affect younger people quite a bit I
think Florida did very well for the
young people for the older people not
quite as
good representative Belcher thank you if
I may and I I I want to make sure I
really have this concept perfectly
distilled so looking at this from a we
understand that there's there's
confounding variables in this that do
make things very
difficult but what we're seeing
consistently is not really any
particular correlation between those
with harsher lockdown measures versus is
those with not now correlation of course
does not equal causation but if we were
to if we were to start out with the
assumption that lockdowns do some good
we should at least see some correlation
right I think so exactly thank you so
I'm not claiming that uh
lockdown generated more
Co but there's no evidence that it
generated any less
Co representative Penza representa
Merchant and then representative
BR so um from the stats that you have
for New Hampshire at one point in time
um New Hampshire had it was published in
the paper um the the highest percentage
of mortality in the country for our
elderly um for Co or correct okay so um
that's by like if you're you know per
capita like so not just in a general
number sense because of course you know
our state is 1.4 million compared to you
know if you've got New York it's Sho so
I just wanted to kind of understand
um based upon the elderly did you see is
that is that age in there do you have
that data so the second panel is uh the
old people I know I can't see it so New
Hampshire is number five the fifth best
the win of all people was Rhode Island
okay and I'm sorry that this is so uh
so
small but but one thing is important to
realize that the temporal Trends are
different to different places so it
could so there were a time for example
where Michigan was the highest in the
country that doesn't mean that they did
something bad because necessarily
because it was just at that point in
time right that's what I'm thinking so I
I I jumped over this graph so this is
Florida so you can see that seasonal the
seasonal mortality in Florida correct um
and there are two peaks in Florida there
is the summer Peak and the winter
Peak but New England doesn't have two
peaks has only one Peak winter Peak is
low in the summer so the southern parts
of the United States have sort of a two
peak summer Peak winter Peak and the uh
the north has only a winter Peak okay if
you go to the summer hemisphere is they
have like a peak in their winter which
is our
summer represent Merchant yeah so
actually if you the gray ones are are
the uh are the all the other states and
if you look on May uh May 2021 sort of
in the middle you can see there's one
state that stands out that's
Michigan you were had in in in uh in
late spring of 2021 Michigan was way
high higher than everybody
else but the thing with uh thing like Co
you have to go through it you can't
prevent it it's it's going to go through
you can postpone it with some measures
but you're going to have to live through
it it's going to it's just going to go
through and you have to just have to as
it goes through you have to protect
those that are at highest risk but if
you if you keep it out completely it's
going to come again that's what happened
in Australia for example they they able
to successfully to suppress it for a
while but then it came yeah so yeah RS
and Merchant
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking the question if you go back to
the slide which very curious again this
is dealing with the death rates this one
or this one please thank you that's
dealing with mortality the death rate so
what I don't see here like the other
slide we're looking only at the death
rate but we don't have a comparison to
the states that had high vaccine rates
I'm trying to get to is the vaccination
rate because if I understood what you
said in Sweden Sweden had had a
relatively High vaccination rate but had
a relatively low death rate but in these
slides here I don't see the same
corresponded or a correlation between
the vaccination versus death rate yeah
I'm sorry I mean there are those slides
okay uh I don't
uh after this presentation I'm going to
dig out a slide from Sweden that shows
very interesting with vaccinations but
the key thing is also that it's not
vaccination rate as a whole as important
it's the vaccination among the elderly
that's important that's the that's what
actually affects the the mortality rates
and that's thank you because that's what
I'm trying to get to is in New Hampshire
like I said before we have relatively
High population elderly wise our age
average age is relatively high in the
country and I think we did a fairly good
job trying to get to is the elderly
getting vaccinated and that's why I'm
trying to get the correlation between
what the state did as far as that
population versus maybe what some other
stat didn't do I'm going to go to
another slide I didn't include it I
should have but uh let me go to another
slide Madam chair I'm going to yield my
question to representative cre uh crean
over here thank you
sure and and Dr cof if that's not
something you have right off that
something maybe you could send to us
thank you madam
chair I do have it somewhere here so let
me ask
see if I can find
it Madam chair if I could just make a
comment well I think that's going to be
one of the struggles for us because we
have experts in particular areas and
we're going to have to put it all
together because it's hard to view any
individual thing in isolation this whole
issue of correlation is not
causation I understand uh so this is a
slide from Sweden uh and this is from
the winter of 2020 21 so this was sort
of the first season where we had access
to
vaccines and on the top is uh cases of
covid by time so you can see that uh
there's two peaks of Co circulation
one sort of peaked in around December
and then there was a second Peak around
April May so this is how the this is how
the virus was circulating so this is all
cases all
ages the first red uh vertical line is
the start of the vaccination
campaign so during this uh first Peak
That season this was the second Peak
because there was one Peak in the spring
of 2020 then the summer came and went
down and then so during that Peak uh the
vaccination only started at sort of at
the end of it and it takes some time for
the vaccines to get effect and you have
to vaccinate people so there was
basically no protection for vaccines
doing that first wave and you can see
that on the lower grade that's the death
covid death you can see that it's a very
high peak of covid death also so that
sort of goes together with the peaking
in
circulations
uh at the second red vertical line
that's when most of the elderly had been
vaccinated but a very small percent of
the total population so they focus on
the old people so most people I think
about 70 had been vaccinated but only 7%
of the total
population so children know uh young
adults know middle AG adults know and
you see you have an other peak of Co
circulation that's just as big as the
first one
but there's almost no
mortality and that's because they
vaccinated the elderly first and they
sort of cut that uh that third Peak
immortality was still they were still
there in in in uh in
infections thank
you representative craan thank you uh
thank you chair thank you for taking my
question I was wondering if you had any
of the
excess mortality data for just the
period from basically 2020 to to before
the vaccines were rolled out um just
thinking about you know trying to make
any conclusions about whether certain
lockdown measures or you know
restriction measures were
effective so I would say based on all
this seems silly and yeah so I would say
that the lockdowns measures were
effective in terms of pushing things
forward but not the point of them right
I mean very few people very few places
were under any sort of lockdown Beyond
you know mid
2020 no there were lots of lockdowns in
2011 also 20 into how are we Sorry to to
keep going but how are we defining
lockdowns I mean it seems like school
closures for example is is an important
part of right so school closures but can
we just say school closures then instead
of lockdowns most people you know
restaurants were open Bars were open
Disneyland was open do you have a
question representing craan yeah I guess
I I was asking you know if we're looking
at the efficacy of of school closures
and things like that why aren't we
looking at mortality just within that
time period instead of getting all the
confounding with vaccination and things
like that okay I think ultimately it's
the it's the mortality in the whole time
period that matters because the season
because of seasonality
some places uh had it had the peaks in
different times than others there was
also difference in when the virus
arrived so it arrived very early to New
York for example there was a place in
Georgia where it arrived very early is
Right early in
Washington so if you look at certain
periods you can always find a period
where one place is higher another one is
low but that's really not what matters
because it's really the whole time
period that matters so I think the best
metric is actually uh excess mortality
in 2020 to 23 that's the most important
measure and then What affected that
that's a combination of things so
lockdowns didn't do much uh school
closures did nothing vaccination quickly
vaccinating all the people was
important uh uh protecting all the
people in nursing homes by reducing
staff rotation
doing more testing in nursing homes that
was important closing universities made
no
difference those are sort of a represent
beler thank you madam chair and I I just
wanted to uh clarify because I I heard I
heard somebody mention something
regarding these slides about uh excess
death all cause mortality but I just
wanted to be specific these slides
regarding vaccines that were
administered in Sweden we're only
looking at covid mortality correct this
is only Co mortality yeah thank you yeah
now there are theories that the adino
VAR Vector vaccines the Johnson and
Johnson and asena can actually have
beneficial effects on other infections
other than covid but that's sted for
another day I
guess so let me go back to
uh the other one and it's almost at the
end
so I think one important part of Public
Health is that public health one of the
principles of Public Health at is that
we have to care about the public health
of
everybody all
ages and all areas all time periods but
also
all uh all social groups whether it's
the upper class the middle class or the
working class or the
poor so this is a a
cartoon uh that uh some person wrote in
uh in
the in uh in uh doing the pandemic so
what we in a way did in the US instead
of doing Focus protect protections for
the elderly who at high risk who did
Focus protection for the well off for
the laptop class which includes me and
I'm sure some of
you so the lockdown have protected the
laptop class of young lowrisk
journalists te scientists teachers
politicians and lawyers while throwing
children to the working class and
highrisk older people under the bus
because it was also the lockdowns
affected the middle and working class
the worst if look at closing schools for
example uh Rich families including the
governor of of California sent the kids
to private schools that were open uh or
they had Tutors or they could afford to
have one parent stay at home and do
homeschooling or they had pot schools
while among the working class and the
poor kids were sometimes home alone
because both of the parents have to work
so uh uh or they didn't have access to
computers to do the online stuff
so we can see this is Boston we can see
that
uh uh poor areas of Boston did worse
wealthier areas of Boston did better
when it come to
covid this is uh
Toronto uh this is only the first part
of the pandemic in 200 uh 20 but you
could see that uh the when in the
beginning everybody was affected but
then locks came that protected the
the the wealthier neighborhoods but not
the working-class
neighborhoods later on so they got it
the first later on the the everybody the
the wealthier neighbors got it as well
and that's also for example in India
they had two ways in the first way the
poor got it and the second way the
middle class and the rich got
it uh Los Angeles we could see mortality
rates were much higher uh among uh uh
those with more
poverty
so in in in my view the in here in the
US I think the the lockdowns were the
worst assault on the on the working
class and the middle class since the
segregation and the in the Vietnam
War so our pandemic response Focus
protection for the privileged not for
those at risk so I think that's a
failure of Public
Health
uh after being exposed while keeping
Society float many workers had strong
long-lasting natural immunity from
having recovered from disease including
nurses and others who took care of Co
patients in the hospitals they would
take care of the co they got infected
they stayed home for a few weeks then
they go back to work take care of more
Co patients then they would
discriminated against by vaccine
mandates that forced them to get the
vaccine even though they already had
immunity that was Superior to vaccine
immunity uh there was no reason to
vaccinate uh people who had already had
uh uh covid and it was in fact unethical
because you were
using uh a short there was a shortest of
vaccines so we're using it on people
didn't need it while people older people
didn't get it in
time uh despite minuscule risk from Co
children have carried an extraordinary
burden during this pandemic because of
the school closures and other lockdown
measures uh together with some
colleagues uh uh we wrote and I think
it's about 80 plus pages of questions
for covid-19 Commission because we hope
that there will be a federal commission
but we are thrilled also that there are
commissions here in New Hampshire I
think most more States should do that so
I really appreciate that so we to put
together a list of question that we
thought should be asked some of those
are relevant for New Hampshire others
are more on the federal level in terms
of what FDA did and ni did and CDC did
but uh you you can find this on the web
uh uh if you take an
interest and I'm happy to respond to any
questions I really appreciate that you
have questions during the presentations
uh I think that's often the best way to
interact so thank you so much well well
thank you doctor for being here um
couple questions for you is one could
you uh email me the your presentation I
can do that yes and could you send us a
link for the norl group with all that
those questions that would be wonderful
I think uh I'll forward it on to all our
members and does anyone else have
questions represent falls off thank you
for being here uh I have question you
mentioned
comparing uh flu and Co and uh I just
wonder there was some data that flu
almost disappeared during the covid uh
uh so what what you what you can make of
it some some some sometimes like
definition
of Co covid case uh maybe sometimes it
was including flu case especially if
there was no testing but maybe some
measures on travel restrictions or other
like helped stop the flu but not the co
uh thank you so there could be some
misdiagnosis I don't think that's the
main reason I think what you allude to
instead is that uh
well I will say there's two things one
is that the lockdowns did affect other
viruses so there were less
circulations of of uh other viruses and
I think including flu but also RSV for
example so some of the childhood
diseases uh you would think that that's
a good
thing and to some extent it is but it
also is to some extent the bad things
because what happened was then you don't
have that sort of continuous exposure
and then once the lockdown is broke they
come again so we had problems with RSV
for example in case after then the
lockdowns were
over
and it might seem harsh but the children
has to build up their immune system and
you they do that at a very young age and
it's very adaptable so that's why that's
I think one reason why they did not uh
they did very well with Co because they
have this adaptable system so uh it's
actually good that they were exposed to
Co at a very young age because Co is no
longer pandemic but it's not endemic
we're going to live with that for for uh
for for the rest of our lives there are
four other Corona viruses that been
circulating for over a century so now we
have five I expect the five to behave
about the same we will be exposed to co
again we will have be home for a few
days but it's the first time that's
serious so if if you could Pro if you
theoretically if you say you can protect
this child from
covid until they are 70 years old that
is a very very bad idea because once
they if they exposed to co for the first
time when they are 70 they're actually
at risk of dying from
it so we don't want to postpone that
exposure uh well the other reason I
think is that there is certain
competition between different viruses so
if one thing comes in it sometimes tends
to reduce the other one and I don't know
that is not my area of expertise so I
don't know exactly what the mechanism is
so I can explain it but they is sort of
competition so that one can compete out
another
one so that's another potential
explanation why why flu because they're
similar in some respects so that's why
flu wouldn't sort of come out and now of
course flu is back because Co is down
okay represent Benda then represent
beler yeah so I just had a follow-up
question question to um to Yuri's
question so at one point in time and I
can't remember because I've been
following this it seems like forever um
there was a a point in time for example
in our country that the CDC wasn't even
tracking so there was a period of time
where they weren't really tracking any
flu cases because all the focus was on
covid and so
um because of that reason it's you know
it's hard to have data and then of
course in the fall when kids went back
to school and stuff like that um the
focus was really still on Co and not on
flu type stuff as well everything was
kind of covid whether it was or not I
don't know it doesn't matter but um I
just was wondering if you had if that
kind of same thing was was what you were
seeing um outside of like the
CDC so I don't think that explains that
we don't have had the I think we truly
didn't have much flu for a while uh
other that was the same phena was seen
in other countries also so I think we
truly didn't have flu for for a while um
now CDC in my view didn't track Co
properly uh because one thing you want
to so this is not with New Hampshire but
one thing you want to do as a CDC is you
want to sort of monitor how many has
been affected so you do a Ser prevalence
studies to find out how many has been
affected now you want to know that for
different areas and over time to see
increases so uh for example Spain did an
excellent survey a very early on in 202
uh 20120 to find out what was the
infection rate for different ages and
different locations Sweden did a survey
was not as as expansive as Spain so was
as good as Spain but they did occasional
surveys CDC didn't do that until I think
two or three years into the pandemic so
we were sort of stuck with having there
was one done in Santa Clara County I
think that was the first one uh but
that's one County in one state and so
that was very valuable information but
we should have had that Nationwide there
was one in Southern California there was
one I think in Idaho very small one so
there was all the spotted things that
some scientists managed to get some
money for but CDC should have actually
done continuous Ser prevalence surveys
in the population so that's one that's
one one where example where testing is
actually important important and you
want to test a random people so you want
to test the combination of older people
and middle-aged people and young people
and
children um and then you want to measure
it to see how it changes over time and
if it's more in some place and less in
other places so that was one thing that
CDC didn't do that they should have done
uh but that's not the fault of and New
Hampshire because that really falls on
cdc's
responsibility represent beler thank you
madam chair and for my usual this will
be a sort of a multi-part kind of
question
um obviously now we have all this
knowledge where we can compare and
correlate the different places with
different policies regarding lockdowns
and when we say lockdowns there there
was quite a bit of differentiation I
mean it's not and you could call it just
schools and some places that's sort of a
light lockdown but we went so far in
many places including New Hampshire as
to shut down beaches nature trails shut
down private businesses even telling
people they couldn't Gather in their
home
uh with more than 10 people with friends
and family um so I my question is the
the first place I saw this happen going
all the way back you know January
February March
2020 I remember seeing videos coming out
of uh out of China out of particularly
Wuhan things like welding of apartment
doors shut um so they they were really
quick on this sort of lockdown model um
so my question is do we know where these
ideas for these really strict lockdown
measures where they came from and what
channels they came through to make their
way from wherever they came from through
I don't know CDC and IH down to the
States and whatnot do we know how that
happened
uh I don't know I don't have a good
answer to that
question I mean China lock down brutally
brutally but they failed those lockdowns
failed uh they kept it under Bay for
quite some time with really really harsh
lockdowns but in the end they had to
lift them and they didn't report all the
co cases they have but I have a Chinese
friend whose friend's father is a
funeral
director somewhere in China they was
just and after the lockdown was lifted
it just went up the
roof and they at that time they hadn't
um yeah so they and they didn't protect
the older people when that happened
properly so a lot of older people died
in China because of that but we don't
have the exact
numbers there are also other countries
that uh that uh didn't report honestly
for example Nicaragua they didn't use
neither lockdowns nor Focus protection
they sort of just let it
happened uh which can be understandable
in a PO country and I think it's better
than lockdowns but uh they were sort of
putting a lid on on the statistics so I
was trying to figure out what was going
on there and then I saw an article about
uh
carpenters and what would Carpenters let
us know about V uh
Co yeah they made coffins and they were
very very busy and they were like you
can sort of say how many more with the
normal and you can sort of figure out
okay Co is going through Nicaragua no
question about it we don't know the
exact numbers because the state doesn't
the country doesn't want to give it out
but it's certainly
there because some people were claiming
that naraga was a perfect example
because they didn't lock down and they
didn't have any covid death but yeah
they did have covid death so represent
Merchant thank you madam
chair early in one of the slides I think
there was a reference to mental
health and any thoughts on
how to deal with the psychology of the
of society of a
pandemic and trying to figure out how to
help
Society deal with a pandemic from a
mental health point of view because a
lot of uncertainty a lot of fear a lot
of unknown um people
panic trying to find a way to help
Society with dealing with the pandemic
from those point of view not So Much
from the vaccines but more from the
psychology of it
all uh that's actually a super critical
issue and it goes back to some of the
basic principles of Public Health that
we used to follow and one of those basic
principle is that you don't do
fearmongering you should never do
fearmongering in public health you
should be very truthful about what the
risks are and they did surveys to both
in UK and in the US is asking if you get
Co what do you think is the risk of
dying and what people answered was about
100 fold higher than the
truth so you don't do fear Ming and I
guess people did it because they wanted
people to take measures to sort of to
lock down properly and stuff but you
don't do uh fearmongering uh
second public health is based on trust
it has to be based on trust and that's
the two-way street on
trust
uh so you are very honest with what you
say and you're very open as the public
health agency with what you say and that
was not the case during this
pandemic uh and you also have to trust
the public if you're a public health
official you have to trust the public so
when you try to Institute mandates
enforc you're going to lose a lot of
that trust and especially if you do like
so one example is the mandating vaccines
for people already that had Superior
immunity from having recovered people
know that people know that we know that
for two and a half thousand years since
430 BC during the Athenian plague so
then to put mandates on that sort of
well that has sort of that has created
huge problems in public health because
now people okay you lied about the covid
vaccine forcing me to get it even though
I had already had
protection are you also lying about the
meil vaccine
about the polio vaccines so now there's
a plummeting in trust for childhood
vaccines which is caused by
these
uh uh pushing uh the covid vaccine to
groups that didn't need
it I mean if you compare Al to the US
and and and
Europe Europe is not vaccinating kids
for Co it's not needed but here it is
that's recommended not many kids are
getting it but it's official CDC
recommendation
so that sort of undermines the trust so
uh I give another example you cannot uh
uh let's take for mask for example so we
know from their previous presentation
but also from the two randomized trials
from Denmark in
Bangladesh that mask has either zero or
minuscule effect on reducing
transmission but they were the mask was
sort
of given as this is put a mask mased on
and you'll protect yourself and
others but that wasn't true because the
Mask doesn't protect but it's not an
innocent error is actually fatal
messaging because what happened was you
have people 75y old person they say okay
I'll put on the mask and I can go to
these rest crowded restaurants and have
a nice dinner with my friends because
the mask will protect me and others well
it doesn't if you're 75 years old or 85
years old you are at risk from Co you
should not go to a crowded restaurant if
you're 25 go good do it but if you're 75
you shouldn't so by giving a false sense
of security from masks in my view
actually kill
people follow up thank
you it's interesting you brought up
the correlation between trust going both
ways
and my concern is
that in order to talk about trust going
on both sides from from the public
health back to the society and Society
back to Public Health that's really
predicated upon having some sort
of sense that science is running what
we're trying to do if we will versus it
being political and I'm trying to I know
this is science base what I'm trying to
get to is the fact that we need to
somehow get back to looking at what
actually happened because I think New
Hampshire has a good story to tell when
you look at our death rate compared to
the other parts in other states given
the fact we adjusted for the age
population having a higher vaccine rate
how do we take that information again
back to trying to at least the people in
New Hampshire that I think we did a
fairly good job maybe we didn't do it
perfectly maybe there some things we
could have done differently but if you
look at the end result
is the sany of life and trying to
protect it and you look at that outcome
and talking about death itself as being
an end
point I think what I'm trying to get to
is how do we somehow communicate that
New Hampshire didn't really do a
horrible job and I want to try to how do
we build and rebuild trust in our own
Department here in the state of New
Hampshire I'm not talking about
nationally but at least in New Hampshire
that we fundamentally did a fairly good
job yeah I think and access mortality is
the most important metric and obviously
New Hampshire did very well so I think
that's something that New Hampshire
should be proud of uh it's not the only
measure because you don't want people to
be have be sick even if they
survive uh a lot of the mental health
problems did not not to death some do
with OPM overdoses or or so but a lot of
the mental health problem does not lead
to death for example I have a colleague
uh at Harvard she she works with autism
uh families with autism and they were
devastated by these lockdowns because
these autism patients didn't get the
treatment they they needed so they were
it was very tragic but didn't die from
it but they sort of deteriorated these
these patients so uh and of course
education doesn't kill not sending
people to school but it has long-term
consequences so mortality I think is in
my view the most important metric but
it's Al there are also other important
metrics including education and uh
and mental health for
example thank um uh thank you again uh
Dr kof um I agree with
um represent Merchant that we need to
focus on the science and everything but
we in the trust but we also have to
realize the harms that were done
especially to the young
population um with with the school
shutdowns whether you call them
shutdowns or lockdowns in the mental
health
uh and I know the children with
disabilities really suffered under these
lockdowns um and yet today after
listening to this we in New Hampshire
still pushing the covid vaccines for the
young population but yet we're hearing
today from an infectious disease doctor
that says that the population that's
most at risk is the over 70 population
ation um and obviously we know that we
did the best we could in our nursing
homes um having as we all sitting here
deal with our County nursing homes um
and know the struggles that they have
gone through and are still going through
and with some of the protocols that were
put in place not necessarily by the
state but at the federal level that
actually harmed nursing homes especially
in my area uh because of certain
mandates um
and I think we need to be cognizant of
that also I think both of you are making
super excellent points because when it
comes to trust there's two things that
are important one is to say if something
goes well you have to tell about it but
also if something goes bad you have to
be honest about it and I want to give
you the example from K from Sweden uh
because swed the public health authority
in Sweden has very high trust level in
the
population uh uh and I know that's both
from surveys I'm talking to people
personally but in the spring of
2020 there were a lot of death in
Stockholm area in the nursing
homes so it was a complete failure in
the nursing homes in the Stockholm area
but the head State technologist Anders
Tel he went out very honest and say yeah
we messed
up and the fact that he actually
acknowledged that that was a
mistake that builds
trust okay uh he realized that it was it
was a mistake he realized says it he he
acknowledges
it that so acknowledging mistakes builds
trust for the future telling the
successes also builds trust for the
future so I think it's sort of you have
to do both of those
things so you make a good team the two
of
you um represent beler then
representative po off thank you madam
chair I I want to talk about the same
thing that we're discussing and get a
little bit more in depth because we do
want to take the a genuinely good thing
that we have which is one of the lowest
um rates of mortality among among the
elderly population which is excellent
and then we also need to balloon that
out and put it in the the entire broad
context of everything that occurred and
what we've just learned I think uh based
on the presentation is that the lockdown
without looking at any other measures
seems to have done more harm than good
but then can we also take for instance
let's say um we can take the average
mortality rate among that older
population in the United States and we
can actually say according to this
average rate versus the rate that we
actually see which is far better in New
Hampshire how many lives did we save
cumulatively with all the measures we
took can we actually say that that
number of lives that were
saved um is
more than the number of lives that are
have been and are going to be lost based
on things like increased rates of cancer
from the diagnoses that were missed the
deaths of Despair and everything else so
do what is your opinion on that do you
think we actually have a net gain in
lives saved or is it too soon to
tell I think those uh are very very
difficult questions to answer and there
are some scientists who doing some
modeling exercises trying to sort of
estimate those things I think that's
pretty
futile
um we can sort of see we can I think
it's possible for example to estimate
how many excess cancer cases were
there because of the lockdowns during
the
pandemic uh we can to date we can only
estimate that for a short period because
we don't know how much that will be in
the future but eventually we'll be able
to do it for a longer time period we can
estimate how many excess o maybe o
opiate overdoses there were or how many
excess cardiovascular but to put it all
together is actually very very difficult
what one can do is we can say well if
New Hampshire had the same rate as New
York how many more people would have
died that you can
do uh
but then there as has been pointed out
there are so many differences so what
what what what was the reasons for that
how much was vaccinations how much were
were school closures well zero but how
much were thought I mean New York sent
sick nursing home patients into Nur sick
Co patient into nursing
homes that was obviously disaster I
assume that New Hampshire didn't do
that uh if if New Hampshire did it was a
big mistake but I assume it didn't and
maybe New Hampshire has a more smaller
nursing home population smaller nursing
home population so for example that's
one thing that makes a difference if you
have big cities with large nursing homes
if if it gets in there can affect a lot
of people if you have more rural areas
with smaller nursing homes so maybe a
doen if it goes in in one it only
affects those doen and the other ones
are protected because it doesn't get
there uh so size of some nursing homes
and staff rotation and all those things
affect things also and most of the most
I think of the difference in the these
covid rates are because of what you did
with the older people because they are
the ones who either died or
survived when it comes to excess
mortality it also includes younger
people and it's actually interesting
to so what did this was to to look at
access mortality by age
group uh because excess mortality if you
have excess mortality in the younger
people below uh we can look at that
here this is that slide that's so hard
to so the one furthest to the right is
15 to 44 there were Fair few covid
mortality there so if you if you compare
that that's basically things a lot
things to do with the lockdowns and uh
um but lockdowns also affect different
areas if you have a small like I live in
a rural area there wasn't many people
were out walking and we were going to
the playgrounds no matter what we just
ignored those
things uh but in the cities they were
sort of closed out
so so that's also a part of things so I
think that was healthy for my my town
that that uh we could go to the
playground with the kids but in some
places they
couldn't represent P off so uh thank you
I want to expand what chair was saying
about kids and uh steel policy is trying
uh to uh protect the group that probably
does not need protection and in the
beginning you showed Wuhan mortality
data by age and then some us data by age
so basically could you qualify that data
in relation of risk for kids and also
like uh put some time stamp so when when
so it looks like from the very very very
beginning in 2020 you it says April 2020
you knew that uh kids are not especially
dying from covid but when did we learn
also like that they're not damaged much
by by this illness uh because some
illnesses like poo it might not kill you
but still you don't want the
consequences and um
so uh would it be
your assessment that we don't need to
protect uh kids and young adults at all
of this disease or do we still need some
protection for them so could you qualify
that
data uh I don't think we need to protect
children from covid there might be some
exceptions with um
um with who are immune immune
compromised for whatever reasons but
other than that no and I think uh they
need to be exposed so that they have
then their immunity for the rest of
their lives because Co is going to be
with them for the next 60 or 80 or 100
years however long they live so uh no I
don't think we need to protect children
from uh and and I mean we know
that there were never any reports of
serious consequences sort of uh uh
long-term consequences from
covid among children there are as with
any viruses you can have long-term
consequences after having covid same
with
influenza but uh it operates about the
same as influenza in that
respect follow up uh can you give me
some time stamp when the science data
was uh back in up this statement was
this one says June previous one said
April so when did we learn that kids
don't actually need that protection so
this is June when we actually knew the
absolute
risk this was uh I published in April
but this was available I think actually
the calculations in end of February
probably so the relative risk that we
knew this age gradient was known before
there was a single covid death in the
US yes from the but it wasn't very well
uh it was known or anybody who was
interested in it but it wasn't very
commonly
known thank
you uh I'm just going to do one final
question um because we're going to break
for lunch um but my question and and you
talked about natural immunity a little
bit so is if an a child or a young adult
got covid is that more beneficial uh for
building up their immunity so that when
they're older and this is and say
something else happens that this would
help them their immune
system so I don't know if
having if the immunity get as having
being exposed a child is better than the
immunity you get as an adult I don't
know if that's the case or not what I do
know is that the risks from the from
having it the first time is much lower
as a child than even so the risk is
lower if you are 10 years than if you
are 50 but it's lower than 50 than 60 I
think the the risk of mortality doubles
around every of every seven years of age
so it's a very rapid thing now I would
say also that this is for
Co we will have another pandemic it
could be different so the the 1918 flu
pandemic it was different the children
were actually and young people were
actually hardly hard hit and it seemed
like old the people had some immunity
maybe because something that they were
exposed to 50 years
ago so uh so it could go it could go
either
way
uh oh uh representative likeus last
question I just wanted to sort of
summarize a
takeaway which would be in any future
pandemic we have to figure out who's
going to be the the most at risk and
that's where we focus our protection is
that General takeaway and not try to
protect
everybody if if if if it's very
different between one group and another
yes that is the take home because we can
never lock down Society completely
either because we need food and
electricity and sewage and garbage
collection and all those things uh so
that is the T Tao measures the other
dimension is that for thing like
influenza whether it was 1918 or or or
or or now or it's covid those are things
that you can't suppress it's fule to do
it there were attempts to suppress it
like the zero
covid uh philosophy that's has no
scientific basis you can suppress
it um Ebola is
different uh we have some Ebola cases in
the US we don't want Ebola to spread
but uh that's different it's very if
somebody's guess Eola we can pick it up
very quickly it won't sort of spread uh
underground in secret it's very sort of
visible but so if we have somebody with
ebola we need to isolate them so Public
Health has the power to isolate people
who POS a threat because they have an
infection and that's an
important uh tool in the public health
toolbox if somebody gets Ebola here in
Concord New Hampshire we should isolate
them in the hospital and everybody
taking care of them should have all this
and not just the a mask a surgical mask
but they have to have all the all the
whole
thing uh so there are times when we need
to isolate people who are sick uh so if
the next pandemic or potential pandemic
is Ebola or something similar then we
have to sort of uh uh suppress that I
mean also uh uh during the last few
years we had the the aox or monkey pox
epidemic here in the US and that was
also very specific uh population that
was at highest risk uh homosexual men so
then we have to focus the protection of
that and there was some discussion in
public health and I have a colleague in
New York City Health Department who was
sort of involved in this and he was
urging well we have to protect the
homosexual men but somehow some matters
like we have to be equal with everybody
but that does a disservice to those who
are higher risk so um uh eventually I
think it came to that but for a while it
was sort of more
General and uh so but that's an example
again we find the population at highest
risk and we protect them because if if
we care about them then we protect them
if we care about the older people we
protect them during Co if if we care
about homosexuals people then we then we
protect them during the the ambox uh
outbreak and so on whatever whatever it
is um if it's children we have to
protect them against
polio so represent represent Merchant go
ahead it's more of a comment than a
question sure I I concur with what the
um doctor is saying
but I also look at I'm a strong believer
in what I call evidence-based medicine
yeah that's very important but at the
same time in order to collect the
evidence you have to go through a
certain studies and trials and so forth
A lot of times it's after the fact so
therefore I want to say thank you for
being here but when we're going into a
pandemic we don't have a lot of facts at
the onset we
have hypothesis but we don't have truly
evidence to say which way we should go
once we get into the pandemic we collect
the facts and data then we have some
evidence to start making decisions but I
want to be sure of the committee that
until we get into that evidence base we
don't have that evidence to drive us so
sometimes with public health we have to
make some decisions based upon not clear
facts so want to be clear factually that
we're doing something and not expect
people in public health to have all the
answers when it starts just it's more of
a comment than a and and in
representative I I I concur with you on
that however I think that some of the
facts
um were were
known more ahead quicker than what we
they were relay to the public and if Dr
Koff would like to comment he is more
than willing yeah actually that's the
third thing in terms of Trust for Public
Health is to say when we don't know we
say we don't know and I have never done
sort of media things before for this
pandemic so I was sort of thrown in it
without wanting to but I did a number of
interviews um after the Great Prank
declaration and sometimes they will ask
me a question and I says well I don't
know the answer to that that's not my a
of expertise and first I felt bad about
it but then I actually realized no
that's actually good because if I say
that they actually trust me more on
those things that we do know something
so there are things we you're right we
gradually knew things uh with the
pandemic uh so we knew about the age
gradients on relative risk very soon but
the absolute risk came uh probably about
half a year later and it was impossible
to know that earlier so as public health
we have to acknowledge what we don't
know but also as public health we have
to actively get some of that information
and some of it was done but some of it
was not done properly so I said for
example that Spain lead the zero
prevalence service very early that was
very good every country should have done
that very soon and
continuously so
uh uh but yeah uh I mean as the
scientist is sort of fascinating to get
this new disease and learning more and
more about it at the same time it's sort
of terrifying because you realize that
people are dying from it so um yeah but
we have to acknowledge when we don't
know
something thank you very much Dr Kula
for being here I I greatly appreciate it
you've been a wealth of information uh
for us um we actually have suon coming
in at 1 but I will see if I can postpone
him until 1:10 if possible so why don't
we plan on being back at 1:10 so we can
at least grab something to
eat
e
welcome commissioner edelblute and ask
him to uh come on up to the
mic not a problem so for the record my
name is Frank GBL I'm the commissioner
of education for the Department of
Education um and you'll see that we have
quite a hefty um packet of documentation
here and I'm happy to leave this with
you but um what I have before me is I
and I uh is a lot of information I'm not
actually going to be reading all of it
but I basically compiled um all of the
press releases and all of the op-eds
that were written from the beginning of
Co kind of leading all the way through
just so that we can kind of Walk Through
The Narrative of how this thing um you
know evolved and how it
unfolded um you know and again I just
want to provide as much information as I
can to you so that you'll have that um
the one uh yeah so we'll just start
there um and actually I'm
gonna
yes yeah this is all Department stuff
all Department yes everything that
associated with our agency so these are
all press releases that we released as
an agency and op-eds mostly that I wrote
as an as a commissioner um I'm actually
just going to start with a little bit of
a timeline before the beginning of this
but so because this the the co stuff hit
our radar fairly early um relative to um
kind of the general public so on January
29th um before there was really any
public conversation about covid-19 I
don't even know that it was referred to
as covid-19 at that time um there was
what is referred to as a health alert um
that the which you guys are familiar
with that HHS puts out um and we
provided so on January 29th we provided
the First Health alert relative to a
respiratory viral disease uh to uh from
HHS put it out we provided that to our
school leaders um we followed up on
February 3D with a webinar for school
leaders um and public school offic
public health officials um you know in
terms of trying to just describe to them
you know what was going on um and then
we provided you know from that point
forward we were providing either weekly
or multi- times a week uh updates to our
schools just to kind of communicate to
them and let them know what was going on
um the the breadth of conversation that
we um got ourselves involved in um was
quite broad uh and so on March 10th as
an example we issued a press release
dealing with upcoming school trips uh
because as you know many schools take uh
field trips especially eighth graders
take off for New York City or Washington
DC and so uh we were providing
information and guidance relative to
school trips starting as early as March
10th um on March 12th uh we had a press
release that announced um that the
department had uh was seeking waivers
for from the US Department of
Agriculture relative to our food
programming um and part of that related
to uh how we were going to be providing
uh food uh many of the USDA programs are
pretty prescriptive in terms of how you
can provide the food program most of it
requireed that a student be present to
be able to receive the food so we were
seeking waivers uh that allowed a
variety of different things and again
I'll leave this whole package with you
but um essentially uh would allow us to
send food home with schools like I don't
know if you know this but like today
under your USDA regulations right if a
kid takes an apple and puts it on their
tray and then they try to leave the
cafeteria they're not allowed to take
the Apple out of the cafeteria and save
it for a snack for later on they pretty
much have to consume the food in the
single setting so there's a lot of
prescriptive rules so we were seeking
waivers to those on March 13th so you
can see it was going pretty fast and
furious at this point um I had a press
release commissioner updat schools on
covid-19 response um and the way that it
was characterized this is a letter that
we sent out to school leaders um from a
worst case um said that the public
health orders for the closure of your of
your facility right so at that point in
time it was possible that public health
might go to a particular school or
School setting and order the closure of
a of a facility they have the authority
to be able to do that uh to a best case
um you know for disruption assuming
disruption and this was a concern that
was happening at this time is that
parents were beginning to refuse to send
their students to school right so the
parents were saying like too scary over
there we're not going to allow our
children to participate in school um and
so on March 12th the State Board of
Education had passed an emergency rule
uh that allowed Stu allowed schools to
conduct remote instruction if they saw
fit so on March 12th that rule was um
passed and on March 13th we communicated
that information um in a relatively
lengthy um you know uh letter to schools
and there's a lot of more information in
there but I'm just trying to move
through the um the the calendar uh on
March 18th um we released so I'm going
to think is that that would be like a
Tuesday I don't have a calendar in front
of me is that a Tuesday anybody March 18
2020 because I seem to recall um I I
believe it was March
16th what day is March
18th was it the
17th was the was a
Sunday 18th was a Wednesday so the 17th
was a Tuesday so the 16th was a Monday
which is what I thought so on the 15th
right okay so this was on that Wednesday
um and so this was on Sunday day the
15th is when we had you know first
communicated out to the um schools about
what we were going to be doing um I mean
I can recall being at the uh Emergency
Response Center that weekend and we sent
out we collected data from
superintendant across the state saying
hey if we have to Pivot to remote what's
this going to look like we created one
of the first heat Maps relative to that
and I think we presented that in a press
re press conference and we updated that
a few weeks later so on this but by the
18th um and again I'm just just trying
to uh give a sense as to what's going on
you know we published something called
healthy habits for well-being a resource
for students parents and Educators for
how to stay strong in the current
anxious environment um and that was
accompanied by an oped by me um which is
which was really protecting Wellness as
well as health um recognizing and I and
and my point of really flagging this for
you is that we knew that there were
mental health issues associated with
public with something whatever action is
going to be taken early on like so if
somebody sort of imagines that that
sneaks up on you but it was like how to
take care of you you know checking in
engaging with other people learning how
to rela like relax go for a walk work in
your garden whatever um on on March 19th
um there was uh in the news answering
your questions about covid-19 so this
was a oped that I put out uh answering
some of the most common questions we've
received as the Department of Education
relative to this um in terms of how uh
you know instructional days will count
what are we going to be doing New
Hampshire was in a unique position
compared to many of other states uh
during this pandemic many other states
had a um a significant uh issue because
they in their state law require that
students attend school for 180 days a
year New Hampshire does not have that
law New Hampshire law states that
schools are required to provide
instruction to students for 18 80 days a
year students are supposed to be
advancing on Mastery right if a kid
knows the material we're not supposed to
like be locking them up um and so we
were just clarifying that that you know
different questions about special
education
students um you know teachers coming in
will part-time and contract School staff
be paid you know how will schools know
that audio and video uh conferencing
apps comply with uh privacy regulations
how are working parents supposed to care
for school a children if they can't miss
work uh can families receive School
breakfasts and lunches how long does
covid-19 survive on paper and other
materials how are lowincome families and
families in areas without Broadband
going to access instruction so trying to
um address a lot of the concerns that
was on so just imagine that was on that
Thursday of the first week right that
we're pushing that information out so um
so the next thing on April 1st a little
bit later I wrote an oped it's called um
CTE students and graduates are ready to
serve and equipped to succeed right so
keep in mind we're still in our first uh
twoe um you know uh flatten the curve
period And I um I put out an oped and uh
I took a little bit of flack on this one
but it said like and you're welcome to
read it later but so the Career and
Technical education programs in the
state prepare students across the state
with skills to this very moment and what
the conversations I was having well and
I'll just some another line in here is
like you know throughout history our
young our young people have stepped up
in times of Crisis and I really U was I
felt like we were um you know and you'll
see the the the messaging here was that
these are young kids who are resilient
strong young kids I mean and think about
like World War I World War II these were
Salient moments in the lives of many of
these kids there's a national crisis and
the young people step in to provide
support and defense um and so you know
we I talked about our health science
students should be able to engage and be
able to do stuff our emergency medical
technicians and fire rescue these are
people who are able to respond our
construction trades at the time I don't
know if you remember we were building
hospital beds in in open places uh you
know automotive and diesel mechanics
keeping the supply chain working
culinary arts kids preparing meals um
and kind of what I what I thought was
the money line I don't know if it worked
or not but um you know through this
programming these students and graduates
have demonstrated that they are ready to
serve and equipped to succeed right so
just trying to uh not uh create an
environment of fear but create an
environment of of uh you know would it's
not the first national crisis that you
know um had been faced and again you got
to put yourself back in that context so
that um maybe these uh students are are
the future right it's and give them an
opportunity here um on April 6 I secured
a waiver uh for School meals that we're
going to allow them to serve meals
through the April
vacation um and then on April 16th
another letter to Educators this is the
letter that uh came because we went from
our second um two week uh flatten to the
flatten the curve to it's going to last
till the end of the year um and so uh
you know um at the time uh you know the
focus was on really um that this is kind
of a it turns out not as sprinting
through this right because when we first
did the first two weeks then the second
two weeks everybody's like okay we can
hold our breath for that long right and
then really the pivot was about that
this it turns out is a marathon not a
Sprint in terms of what potentially is
going to happen if it's going to last
through the rest of the year and just
emphasizing that uh you know we're going
to have to continue through this but
that school is in session like don't
we're not like this is not a go home and
not do anything and truthfully and we
did receive um some praise nationally
about this kind of a philosophy but
uh you know we pivoted over to remote
instruction like the philosophy that we
have as an agency is that kids are
learning all the time right so these
kids if we just sent these kids home
they were going to be learning things
but it might be stuff that we don't
actually want them to be working on um
and remote instruction at least afforded
us the opportunity to be able to weigh
in on what it is that they were going to
be learning if they're not with us and
so recognizing that stud you don't get
to like sending the kids home didn't
shut off student learning sending the
kids home might have shut off our input
into what they were going to be learning
um but it certainly wouldn't have shut
off learning um on May 1st um so this is
another two weeks later so uh um at a
release about applying lessons of remote
instruction when we go back to school so
we already talking about Okay so we've
been in remote instruction at this point
in time for about five weeks um and uh
just describing some of those
experiences and I I told a story about a
couple of students about Leslie uh these
are they madeup names who had a really
hard time with right she misses her
friends in her extracurricular programs
the instruction is okay but I miss my
friends I miss my sports and this was a
young it's a true story about a young
lady who was very into the sports and
she's like oh my gosh I can't do my
sports right and then another one is a
you know a young lady named Melanie who
felt she was now engaging her material
more than ever um was the feedback that
we got from both her her parents as well
as the schools um she uh you know
basically could do stuff at her own pace
right and engage it on her own terms and
so she happened to somebody who had a
job at a pizza parlor her job was
continuing um and so she could engage
her curriculum in a more flexible way um
and so um you know with the Academic
Year almost over we are the idear here
is we're already planning for the fall
so with this Academic Year almost over
we're already planting fall and a new
meaning of back to school we need to
learn what this per learn what this
period of remote instruction has to
teach us well it is appropriate that we
consider learning Gap gaps for students
that may have manifest as a result of
covid-19 uh the persistent and
inequitable learning gaps existed before
covid-19 and so I guess my point here is
like again early like everybody goes oh
my gosh there's learning gaps like you
know we were talking about learning gaps
on May 1 of the first year saying like
this is learning gaps are not new
they're existing they're being P you
know they're being examplified by uh
covid you know um you know and we talk
about the mental health issues again pre
pandemic teens Su you know so pre-
pandemic we had learning gaps you know
pre pandemic we had teen suicide
substance misuse and a host of other
mental health issues were on the rise at
reach and reaching alarming issues um
Paul lean LeBlanc for the president of
uh SN had a quote there he says American
higher education cannot respond to the
crisis with a calcified industrial
production model of learning um and this
same approach applies to our K12 system
um on May 11th uh we had uh announced
our we called it the school transition
reopening and redesign task force start
um it was a group that we pulled
together to figure out okay so how we
going to get these kids back into school
what is that going to look like uh the
title of the release is back to school
um on May 27th parents uh we had a
survey that we released um you know open
to everybody uh that survey ultimately
collected over 56,000 responses from
across the state I think to this dat it
might be the uh a survey that has more
responsive than any survey survey in the
history of New Hampshire um on June 4th
we received our first allocation and we
distributed $ 33.4 million in cares
funds acts um to schools to be able to
uh work on mitigation and education
issues um on June 12th I got another
extension associated with the meal
waiver on June 19th uh the state issued
guidance for in school summer programs
right because we have a lot of esy
students uh extended school year
students and um so we worked very hard
on that guidance for students with uh in
particular most of the summer much of
the summer program is centered around
students with special education needs um
and there was a lot of difficulty so
some of these are students who have um
needs like you know they've got
particular types of autism they're not
capable of wearing a mask they're not
capable of you know uh certain
mitigation protocols simply not going to
happen um you know they they have um you
know issues relative to bodily fluids
and stuff like that so a lot of of
technical questions about how to manage
students with high need medical issues
um that would be entering into some of
that summer programming um and so we we
spent a lot of time doing on that um on
June 19th because a lot of kids were
disrupted I wrote an opet about don't
let covid-19 derail your college plans
about and kind of just laying out
Pathways for students like you don't
have to put your life on hold here right
like we get to keep moving forward um is
I think you know I share that one with
you on that in that context and again
there's lots of details you can go
through and you can read them um on July
1 uh you know iing uh we um talked about
equipping teachers to help students
returning from remote instruction right
so now they're going to be back so on
July 1 we're already here we we released
some training programs we worked with an
organization called cast who has a
program called Universal Design for
Learning uh to basically recognize so
Universal Design for Learning recognizes
and when kids come into your learning
environment they're at all different
levels and so given the fact that we had
just spent from you know March 16th
until the end of the school year at that
we imagined that there would be a lot of
variability or an amplified variability
among those students uh so we provided
free training training programs to
teachers to say like okay so what are
the strategies I'm going to use for
instruction when these kids come back to
us and I got a room full of kids that
now the standard deviation of learning
is is far greater um on July 10th
setting realistic expectations for
school reopening um and so again we had
collected uh you know um throughout the
summer we had our start thing we
collected 56,000 responses and the tone
here so again the the the title might
bury the lead really where it
says uh setting realistic expectations
for school
reopening um and I'll just read a couple
of paragraphs from this oped it said
when we return to school we will need to
be realistic about our expectations for
a couple of reasons first it is unlikely
that children even some of the older
ones will follow our wellth thought out
plans exactly as imagined they are
children that is not a flaw um we also
need to recognize the negative effect on
those same children of an overly
constrained environment children are
designed to be curious Learners and
explorers stifling that Curiosity also
has Health consequences to our children
and I do not want us to lose sight of
that right so recognizing you know just
because you think you've mitigated the
uh the the spiral disease doesn't mean
that you've not created an alternative
um otogenic type of a of a problem um
and so then on July 15 uh another news
release about we've come a long way it
was an oped actually and I talk about
you know how we started on January 29th
which I talked about on February 3rd and
all the kind of
communications um but I basically am you
know St today we're in a very different
place from where we were you know on
March 15th uh the governor issued the
first emergency order temporary remote
instruction uh for public districts
today we're in a very different place we
have vastly more knowledge and
information about this disease um all of
this knowledge among other inputs has
gone into our plan to safely reopen
schools in September we can now safely
conduct in-person instruction and
provide accommodations for students and
staff with underlying health risk and
create
vulnerabilities um but each City and
each City and town in New Hampshire can
craft a safe and effective return to
school we are not the first to travel
down this road even at that time I don't
know if if you all know it but um 20
countries have already opened
educational institutions by that you
know if you looked around the globe and
you could see what was kind of going on
there so we knew where that was going um
so on August 14th um doe publishes five
steps to covid card it's basically five
steps to expect if your student or staff
member test positive for covid just
explaining to people you know how this
process would work again you can read
through this students with IEPs need
full support so this was an interesting
oped I wrote with a a woman named
Stephanie Patrick who some of you may
know she works for the disab rights
Center um and we were having difficulty
uh you know students with disabilities
were still having trouble getting a hold
of uh you know some of the services that
they they needed and and many of these
students some of our most vulnerable in
the state made little or no progress and
in some cases regressed during the
initial remote instruction and support
period this spring and that cannot
continue is what I've written you know
reading another paragraph while some
schools may have adopted a hybrid or
remote instructional model for the Fall
start many of the students with IEPs
require imperson supports and services
that simply cannot be provided remotely
remotely there are no prohibitions on
our districts by Pro to providing these
in-person Services again you know going
back into the you know late June we
provided guidance for how to do that um
a coalition of educational associations
went so far as to suggest the best time
to consider compensatory education
supports and services is after the
pandemic subsides we could not disagree
more and you have to understand like
when Stephanie and I disag agree on
something this is kind of like
Monumental it's a good thing right um
you know these responses are neither
appropriate nor legal when planning for
the educational programming of students
with disabilities so just weighing in on
the importance of making sure that that
happens on September 1st uh the New
Hampshire schools um will soon receive
we received an allocation of
230,000 cloth face masks as part of a
nationwide program uh that distributed
over 125 million uh cloth masks to
American public and private schools
across the state so that was on
September 1st um that we received those
and and distributed those back out um
those were from the CDC so it was the
the US Department of Health and Human
Services allocated the 230,000 Mass to
New Hampshire and we worked with the New
Hampshire guard to get those distributed
um on September 10th we allocated
additional $7 million to VX uh which is
a virtual Learning Academy so uh you
know because what we found is that many
of the students uh were not interested
in coming back uh at that time but we
need to make sure they keep getting
educated and so there was a a a quite a
large surge that was going on relative
to VX um as well many of the schools
that did open up and had families that
did not want to return to school um
those families uh the schools would be
able to point them towards um VX on
September 30th staying connected with
remote Learners um we provided an
infographic to assist New Hampshire
Educators to keep tabs on their students
that were learning from home because we
still had some students didn't want to
come in they were learning from home um
because we saw a sharp drop off of
contact by student support functions and
wanted to help support them to stay
connected with those students even
though they're learning
remotely um on January 7th we got $156
million um on January
14th um this is we rolled out a program
our first in nation we worked with salon
and we rolled out a tutoring program
with school house. world uh first
program in the country on that one um
then we got the 156 million first they
told us we would get then they sent it
to us we passed it out on February 17th
uh new federal guidance related to the
operation of New Hampshire schools um
cdc's new educational phase mitigation
guidance and suggested testing strategy
would Place unnecessary barriers to
inperson learning so this was a
statement from Dr Chan and myself uh
pushing back on um you know some of the
CDC um probably one of the first uh you
know beginning to see some some daylight
in there pushing back on some of that
CDC stuff uh then on don't see a date
here but I think it was in March we
received another $350 million uh of Co
relief funds so that brought the total
so we were about $650 million of
additional funds that went into the
system um on April 12th uh we B I wrote
an opportunity and I wrote an oped
called an opportunity for change um and
I the the the um the last sentence in
the oped again money line says uh the P
this pandemic has given us all a bunch
of lemons is anyone interested in making
lemonade um because I am a little bit
optimistic um on April 15th New Hamshire
Department of Education announces
support for districts to provide
additional services to students with
disabilities uh so we actually provided
uh $1.8 million of funding for any
compensatory services that students with
disabilities might need and made that
available to everybody um on June 9th uh
New Hampshire Department of Education
division of public health issues joint
statement regarding masks in schools um
and says uh you know with the levels of
covid-19 in our communities decreasing
around the state New Hampshire division
of Public Health recommended last week
that schools can safely remove masks and
outdoor settings regarding L of a
person's vaccination status yep that was
June 9th 2021 and I'll leave this whole
packet for
you yeah go
ahead oops sorry now I'm forgetting so
in September when um in September when
the September 10th or whatever in 2020
when the schools went back that was kind
of where you said 230,000 masks were
distributed um at that point how many
schools were open do you know that data
I can probably go back back and collect
it I don't have that now with me because
there was still a a whole bunch of
schools that were not open there were
schools that were in hybrid as well and
then there were schools that were fully
open correct okay yeah exactly
um okay and so just emphasizing there
should be flexibility in school Mass
policies so that if the situations
arrive we need to take care of that um
on June 16th we released uh two million
dollars for what is referred to the yes
every student program um this was
basically provided you know scholarship
up to um a thousand dollars for students
to just go out and hire tutors to be
able to support them um if they were
behind in school um and then on June
22nd um we released I didn't I'm
surprised we didn't have a release on
this but we had announced our recovering
curiosity program so we provided grants
we're in our fourth year now uh every
kid goes to camp um I'll take a I will
pause for a moment or take a side detour
and just talk about that program because
it was one of my favorite but it I think
it we tries to reflect what we were
trying to accomplish in New Hampshire um
so every kid goes to camp rekindling
curiosity was a program that came out of
conversations I had with a lot of um you
know National calls with school leaders
and everybody was talking about the
learning loss and saying like oh my gosh
and um and and I'm not diminishing the
learning loss uh but they were making
recommendations of how we had to have
extended school days we wanted to do
summer school and we had to have
Saturday school and I was just thinking
to myself and I'd sit on these calls I'm
like there's no no kid in New Hampshire
who wants to who who would agree with
the what these people are saying right
what we really needed to do is to just
allow these kids get back to a sense of
normaly and I that what I used to
describe it as I said I hope I want kids
this summer to be able to all of them to
go to Camp to go outside climb a tree
skin their knee get grass between their
toes right they needed to just be kids
again we as a society had already um
done a lot of stuff but part of that
Partnership of providing scholarships to
go to camps is we had a partnership with
the community Behavior Health
Association um and so we were training
all of the camp counselors in camps to
be able to uh recognize they weren't
counselors but they would B basically
say like a kid who's here hey I think
this kid may have some struggles and so
they would then refer them to the
community Behavioral Health Association
um they were providing Staffing on site
most of the camp was like one day a week
um and then if a kid needed additional
Services they would work with the family
to connect them up to full services so
um so I I was sort of felt like and I I
still like this program a lot I feel
like you can have beths of Both Worlds
right we can have kids running around
but we can also kind of figure out the
kids that might need extra supports and
try and support them and you can read
more about that um and then on September
13th I wrote in oped um it says how
about health as a CO exit strategy um
just um focusing on the fact that uh um
and again you can read through it I'll
read a paragraph This study provides
compelling results that support the
importance of a focus on lifestyle
choices for healthy outcomes uh those
choices we know have a positive effect
on covid-19 resilience uh we also know
that they have had a positive effect on
resilience in many of the diseases as
well as the severe covid-19 outcomes
just trying to you know we had talked a
lot about mitigation strategies all
along but how about resilience
strategies of healthiness is uh and a
lot of the statistics here bear out that
the individuals who had the worst
outcomes from covid were individuals who
had um you know preexisting conditions
comorbidities and stuff like that um
October 7th um
you know we this is a a press release um
about covid response so we have learned
throughout the past that most students
are happy and learn best in during
inperson instruction which provides them
with the greatest opportunity for
Success remote learning should be a last
resort and should only be in place for a
short amount of time if found to be
absolutely necessary for safety reasons
and that was in response to a school
that was um going to to I think Kelly's
point was going to remote um I just I
have a couple of other this is a couple
of social media things so the union
leader reported uh a quote from me that
says institutions of higher education
should not be imposing vaccine mandates
but instead should be focusing their
efforts on supporting students and staff
improving academic achievements and also
allowing employees to decide what works
best for their families um that made a
few people unhappy um take four uh this
pressured overreach requiring the
implementation of a vaccine mandate for
University employees was unnecessary and
unproductive to our efforts to keep our
community safe um resulting in some
unhappy
responses um and then this is somebody
commenting on that on uh November 11th
as if he hasn't already done enough
damage to our Public School System NH
commissioner has suggested I just like
the hindsight aspect of this has
suggested recruiting unvaxxed teachers
um from New York who are protesting V
mandates just what our state state needs
right now um it's really time for
parents to organize and so this was in
response to um New York had imposed a
vaccine mandate on school teachers and
many of them quit their jobs as a result
of that and so I had made the suggestion
that maybe we could find some good
teachers because we were needing
teachers and that maybe if we recruited
some from that those individuals that
might be good um might be a good idea to
look at that um and then there was a
press release on December 14th New
Hampshire assessment results um
participation two things happened in
assessment participation rates declined
um Statewide 38% of students SED
proficient uh or above math compared to
48% uh in ela we were at 52% versus 56%
and in science we're at 37% versus
39% um and so just amplifying and
talking about the fact that we recognize
we did have some learning gaps that were
manifest in there um although I think
that we even want the pre uh covid
results to be a focus um and then uh
just another social media post um from
the Nea uh questioning you still oppose
masks or vaccines and masks right now
I've never said that um but I I oppose
vaccine mandates um but I but that's how
it's interpreted so um providing
educator then I did a press release on
January 28th providing Educators with
tools uh to build uh
resilience um so back in that classroom
just trying to equip our Educators so
that they can be as effective as they
can with a program like Reg regulated
classroom um had a full-on campaign
about leaning into literacy to make sure
again literacy is the foundation for the
instruction so any of our kids who had
any kinds of gaps in that literacy to
make sure that we're closing those gaps
um and then there's one I'm going to
back up to but uh so August 17th New
Hampshire expands access to free online
tutoring we had our tutor.com in fact
let me back up to another one I'm just
going to lay out for
you kind of a some of the Investments I
think it's in this
no I don't see it there um it's in here
somewhere you'll be able to find
it uh when our when our children Prosper
we all Prosper was a September 26 2022
coming out the other side of the
pandemic we gain a bit of perspective on
what took place and we can look back
which is obviously what you're doing
there is much we did um well and there's
stuff that we can learn um but I want to
just kind of outline kind of the some of
the Investments that the department made
throughout this process um so very early
on we purchased a Statewide license for
everybody to Canvas learning management
system um part of this stems from the
fact that what we saw was uh you know a
a wide variety of instructional
opportunities from you know some of our
districts were right on it they had
online learning resources their teachers
jumped in and were going we had some
districts that were uh you know sending
out manila envelope packets and uh you
know so not that good so we got a
learning management system so that
everybody could have access we then did
a contract with Discovery Education
which basically filled it with
highquality instructional materials so
every one of our kids could have access
to a learning online learning management
system uh Discovery Education and this
is you know this was back in the in May
of 2020 or 2020 um we then uh did a
contract with Gran State College to
basically train all of our teachers over
the summer on that uh how to use those
tools and how to uh execute that well uh
we did our leaning into literacy program
we did we had three separate tutoring
programs we did School house. world we
did yes every student we have tutor.com
uh which is providing even today 247
tutoring uh we talked about a rekindling
curiosity program the regulated
classroom and one trusted adult to help
our Educators when those kids are back
in there to be able to uh you know
engage those kids who maybe some of them
forgot how School Works um we did a
contract with we talked about the
community Behavioral Health Association
and then the last one is graduation
Alliance uh which was a one-on-one um
mentoring program for students uh so
schools could just sign kids up and they
would basically get I used refer to it
and I hope this doesn't sound bad but
they would get an extra grandparent uh
who would you know call them text them
in the morning hey did you go to school
today did you do your homework uh so
it's just basically a one-on-one
mentoring program to make sure that kids
had supports to so that they could be
successful um you know in uh you know
just
um reflecting back um um you know
there's obviously always things that you
might change you might do a little bit
differently but in hindsight it's always
tough to to deal with but I just thought
uh showing up and and walking you
through kind of the pathway that we took
might be helpful uh thank you
commissioner for all that I do have a
couple of questions okay um then I'll
defer um my questions are about how
one how did the guidance come to the
Department of Education was it through
Dr Chan was it through CD C was it
through
DHHS um and I want to talk about
masking social
distancing um and I do want to applaud
you for taking a positive approach
instead of a fear-mongering approach um
when when dealing with the education
because we know uh that fear can
actually exasperate mental health uh so
I do want to applaud you for that um so
those are just a couple of the questions
I'd like to know if you can again I mean
Dr Chan should probably weigh in on this
as well but um like so Dr Chan was
responsible for public health and would
set the public health policy um and then
we were responsible for then
communicating that and working with our
schools to implement that policy um in
the
districts okay thank you does anyone
else does anyone have any questions
represent beler thank you madam chair
and thank you commissioner for being
here um so my question is it's a little
bit little complicated let me set the
stage so I think one of the things that
I hear most about that people are not
terribly happy with that happened during
Co time is is how long schools had
remained closed and the learning loss
and other issues that occurred with
students and I think part of our
responsibility here in this committee is
really trying to untangle this knot a
little bit because this is really
complicated it's not for the most part
it's not as though you have a single
person making all these decisions so
we're trying to figure out where
different things were coming from and I
can look right here at even all the way
back in June or July of 2020 an NPR
article you got the president in active
uh conflict openly with the CDC guidance
that's being put out on schools um it's
a very complicated situation so my
question with all of that is uh can you
give us an idea
of where some of this guidance may have
been coming from for as far
as because again it not all the
decisions were made by you or by the
governor a lot of this was even handled
locally so where were some of these um
guidances coming down from and when it
comes to especially the federal level
and the CDC or any other relevant entity
what carrots and sticks may have been
brought to bear to see their guidance
put into place at the state
level yeah um so it's a complicated
question so I'll try to do my best to
answer that question um so my uh
understanding and my belief is that um
you so Public Health was responsible for
public health guidance and they were
issuing the public health guidance um I
believe that much of that guidance was
taken from CDC and other words like we
were pretty much following CDC guidance
I'm not sure if my memory is correct but
I believe the maybe one of the first
deviations from the CDC guidance took
place in our reopening school guidance
that we issued in July of 2020 um
because you'll recall at that time and
again this stuff all seems kind of like
uh a little dystopian in hindsight right
but they were saying like oh if you're
six feet of social
distancing um is what the CDC was
recommending but I believe that Dr Chan
um and I don't know if it was I I
believe there was like an American
Academy of Pediatrics article that said
three feet is a good number right right
and so I believe our school reopening
guidance said 3 feet is a good number um
and I so I would say like that was a I
think maybe the first that I was that I
knew about maybe we like deviated a
little bit and we said like no we're
going to tail of this to New Hampshire
and we put our own spin on there um but
again that was guidance to the schools
many of our schools at the school level
um had board votes and adopted we're
going to follow the CDC guidance right
and so you know apparent might call me
up and says like well your school
reopening guidance suggests 3 feet and
but the school had adopted the CDC
guidance so they're they basically had
married themselves to that kind of a of
a of a line and so does that kind of and
so I think essentially you know like Dr
Chan was the one who was setting that
policy in terms of what we would do and
then we would work and then we would
work in terms of carrots and sticks or
we're not carrots and sticks um there
were you know if I received concerns
from parents I was reaching out to
school leaders and saying like hey I'm
hearing from your community they're
concerned about this they're concerned
that I you know um I mean there was a
lot of different uh circumstances where
that would might manifest itself I mean
I had had you know a student I'm
recalling an incident a student an
autistic student who was incapable of
wearing um you know he's in a CTE
program and a welding program right and
they were like well he has to wear a
mask and I'm like well he can't wear a
mask because of his uh you know the the
type of autism that he he deals with and
we had even before the pandemic had
already accommodated the non- masking we
would have this kid welding without a
full welding mask we let him use welding
goggles because he could tolerate the
welding goggles but he couldn't take the
whole mask but when we relative to the
covid we were suggesting that the mask
was going to be required um even though
we knew we would be able to isolate the
child the student from other students
you know at least the six feet distance
and stuff like that so so I think you
know there's just lots of fistic types
of conversations and and um uh and
information that you tried to you just
tried to problem solve all day long
represent Merchant did I answer all of
your question it was a pretty complex
question it was I just wanted to dig a
tiny bit deeper because when I when I
was talking carrots and sticks what I'm
what I'm really interested mostly in is
is there was there anything coming down
from the federal level suggesting that
if you follow or if you don't follow our
CDC guidance we might come after your
funding or or you get extra funding if
you do this or that was was there
anything like that going on I'm not
aware of that happening at the education
for the education funding there was
there were plenty of strings but I don't
recall those being some of them
represent Merchant thank you I think
actually representative Ed Abel had her
hand up first Z Perler
please thank you for being here I have
to say this is all giving me a little
bit of PTSD if you were recounting
everything I can connect you with the
community Behavioral Health Association
I didn't even have a child in school
um so I'm not a can I just respond to
that for a moment again you know I mean
this is the point like I mean we're this
is not the first national emergency that
that as a country we've been through and
this is my point and um you know so I I
hope that I don't know if it's the case
but I hope that students would be able
to look to adults and says like I was
empowered I was encouraged I was
inspired by the response not one of of
uh of instilling anxiety or fear in our
students right so and I don't know what
I didn't live through World War I or
World War II so I don't know how that
all played out and maybe there was a lot
of anxiety Then but the same yeah you
know but in the end it gives you
strength and you rise above and all that
um so I'm just trying to to remember um
and as this relates to schools there was
a lockdown period a required lockdown
period that was a the emergency
declaration by the governor was that
about because I have a couple of
questions was that about three months or
six I can't the way that worked so the
first one occurred in executive order
number one it happened on March 15th um
and it was for a two-e period um then
that was continued for another twoe
period and then on April 16th uh it was
announced that that would continue
through the end of the school year so
it's not a fixed period it depending on
when your school year ended but through
the end of that school year um it did
not extend into the summer programming
which is why we were putting out
guidance in June saying like hey your
summer programming here's what this is
going to look like and much of the
summer programming is designed for
special education students esy and so
that's why we were so adamant about
trying to get those kids you know with
disabilities into the school over the
summer thank you so just as a followup
so what what I was trying to figure out
is after the required lockdown
period whe whether a school wanted to
have lockdown whether they wanted to
have masking whether they wanted to have
a CO a covid vaccine mandate was that
all a local locally based decision with
guidance from public health correct well
and guidance from the Department of
Education as well so um and so I don't
uh I prefer to use the term remote
instruction as opposed to lockdown
because quite frankly you didn't lock
these kids I mean you could send them
home you could try to lock them up
they're not they're still doing
something right so um and so essentially
what happened is we provided guidance we
had our start committee we provided
guidance for how schools could safely
reopen um and you know so and then
school districts took that guidance and
made a determination locally as to how
they were going to operate the
department through the State Board of
Education we did have a rule that you
know that remember that rule that we put
in place on March 12th of 2020 that
enabled them to do that because prior to
this they would not have been able to do
that that right so we enabled them
through that remote instruction rule to
be a and then to be able to do that and
then we provided them guidance for how
they could uh if they were doing that or
if they were doing inperson instruction
how they could safely do that as
well so so just as a followup as we're
unwinding the knot and figuring out what
the knots are yeah yeah I know
really uh as far as the state response
versus local school response there were
many decisions that were made locally
that were simply based on state guidance
as opposed to
requirements as far as the response to
co I'm not sure I understand the
question but I mean there were many
decisions that were made locally they
may have followed the school guidance or
they may have decided to uh represent
bel's question they may have decided to
follow the CDC guidance instead of that
guidance right I mean that's what what
I'm trying to say is that our charge is
to look at the state response and I'm
just trying to separate out what the
state was requiring versus what
decisions were being made at a local
level with guidance that they chose
whether it was yours or the cdc's or
ours or the or um Public Health as well
right right yeah right so all of the
guidance documents that the department
put out were vetted through the the
Department of Public Health right like
so we weren't issuing guidance to
schools that was not vetted and approved
by public
health represent Merchant and then
represent cran thank you madam chair and
thank you commissioner for being
here one of the things we heard earlier
was the variance in how this pandemic
impacted different parts of our society
based upon social economic
factors in saying that given the fact
that in New Hampshire we have
communities with various
resources and for remote learning to be
effective one of the things that think
is critical to it is technology
resources so what kind of guidance did
the department provide to those
communities that didn't have the
technology resources because if they
don't have those
resources what's the option for them
yeah um so what we did is we worked very
hard to close that resource Gap um
including um you know working in the
supply chain to expedite uh like I can
remember making phone calls I think to
China trying to expedite stuff to get
you know Chromebook orders delivered on
time um you know who was a really good
partner in this process was the uh the
carriers throughout the process um right
so if I had a student who was in remote
instruction and was having difficulty
with internet access um we would
actually uh like I could I I have a
specific instance right at a kid on a
dead end Road like a dirt road end of
the line and was and the the service was
not good um you know I I think it was
Consolidated actually went out and
replaced the switch to upgrade that
household so that we would be able to
get access to that household so um we
just problem we we were doing problem
shooting throughout the process to be
able to uh solve access um and resource
problems for students um Chester I
thought had a very creative thing they
literally put like hotpots on some of
their buses and drove their buses and
parked them in apartment building
parking lots uh so that the students
would be able to gain access that way so
it was really a function of just trying
to figure out how to solve those
problems we had um you know uh churches
uh that opened up and opened their doors
and said hey students can come here and
they can learn because we got Wi-Fi and
so if you're don't have access you can
come here um we had many schools who
opened their buildings two students to
be able to come in right so maybe they
were doing remote but they would have
they could allow kids to come in and
gain access to uh you know the Wi-Fi
there if that was an issue so um we
tried to not have any of the Hales and
the Have Nots but to try and make sure
that all of the students had those
resources um and were engaged with those
resources followup thank you thank you
for that as
well do we have any um comparative data
so try trying to look at data try to
make this um sound as much as possible
based upon the data do we have any
comparison between communities that had
a lot of the resources the ones
that had to rely upon other entities
including the Department of Health and
the state and so forth to try to close
that Gap so is there any kind of data we
have available to us and looking at
maybe test scores and so forth and
saying because of the fact these
communities struggled with trying to get
the technology either be economically or
the bandwidth wasn't available to them
and so forth compared to those
communities that probably were blessed
with more resources and therefore didn't
have to go through that closing of the
Gap right so we have a lot of data in
terms of student performance uh what we
don't have is where those gaps were
closed and how those gaps were closed um
so it would be difficult to uh connect
the two of those dots um quite frankly
at this time right you know uh because
and it it would have it would be a
uneven thing uh in terms of you know
this one I got theirs their Chromebooks
on Tuesday these ones I was able to get
theirs on Thursday I don't know if you
could actually make the case that that
there's some kind of a correlation in
terms of variability in terms of uh
implementation really I think what
you're going to find is it it would it
drove all the way down kind of more at
the educator level in terms of how
effective the educator was in during
that spring period of time in terms of
engaging and doing the remote
instruction
and so and that that degree of
Effectiveness varied uh we provided a a
ton of training resources uh you know
working with gr State College in
particular uh to help them if they if
they needed that skill hone to make that
resource available to
them followup thank you one more
question in regards to students and I
think you spoke to it before about
summer camp and getting out grass
between your toes and skinning your
knees and all the good stuff and a lot
of that's based upon why people go to
summer camp is a social part of it and
we're social animals we have a tendency
to want to be with people and when
you're sort of at home by yourself
you're not really socializing with your
peers is there any data out there in
which we can show that because there was
the issue of lack of
socialization um that it had an impact I
mean I'm trying to look at both sides of
this equation and saying that yes
there's a education component to it but
getting somebody in a classroom is not
just about the teacher it's also being
with your peers socializing with all of
the folks and so forth and I can go back
when I was in school I look forward to
catching up with my student body as much
as probably more so than going to listen
to my teacher yeah and and I think
you'll see some information in this
packet about that I wrote I've written
about that but I I and again this is why
like before I'm trying to I was trying
to think when I put that First
Wellness yeah so on March 18th right so
on March 16th we pivoted to remote on
March 18th we put out healthy habits for
well-being right like so that's not and
and again part of the I mean we did that
but one of the reason I want to flag it
is because that wasn't a surprise right
like would you articulate that there's a
social component to this when you say
those things um like that was well known
um that this was a this this should be
important to us to make sure that we're
taking care of the uh that the wellness
and quite frankly that and you'll see
that resource was for students but for
parents for and for my Educators as well
right like I wanted everybody uh to be
taken care of um and and to pay
attention and they're they're were're
and and they're flagged in this in this
resourc there's you know sometimes
obvious and very simple uh disciplines
that you can use
to keep that mental health strong and to
be resilient right it doesn't it's not a
complicated thing thank you represent
craan um so my question actually
connects back to the previous answer um
so as somebody who did live through this
period with three kids in school um I'm
getting a different kind of ptsg um and
I was wondering um so you mentioned all
the different resources that that were
made available for teachers and learning
how to um you know provide Prov their
remote instruction um I definitely did
see a huge variation um even within my
my kids own teachers um so I would
really love to hear a little bit more
about that kind of um guidance that you
presented you know at the beginning when
um schools were sort of all figuring out
their own thing and we realized this was
going to be an ongoing thing um a little
bit more about that summer program
because I don't remember that and then
um also what you continued to provide um
into this school year as I think as
teachers began to
actually apply that and see you know see
how it was going in the real world
situation and then uh with hybrid too
once that switch over happened I would
love to hear more about that thank you
yeah great so happy to talk to you about
that um and and I think you're
emphasizing what I was trying to
communicate here like if you wanted to
try and find the correlation it was
really educator by educator specific
right um I'm not proud of this but I do
know that I had Educators who seemed
like they loaded assignments on Google
Classroom on Monday
and they checked them on Friday
sometimes right and that was the extent
of their remote instruction um and that
was some of the feedback again this
would be like a worst case scenario but
I I can tell you I took incoming calls
from families describing that as a
circumstance all the way to Educators
you know Educators who turn their living
rooms into entertainment platforms for
them to engage the kids and find ways to
do it so it really was I think to your
point it was very educator um dependent
in terms of that experience in terms
terms of the remote instruction um so
again the resources that we brought to
them were a learning management system
right a canvas Learning Management
platform um a we filled that with
Discovery Education and I don't know if
your children or your school district
use Discovery or not I can't tell you
today a 100% of the schools in the state
of New Hampshire are using
Discovery you know whether they all got
on board on day one or not I don't you
know like I I think it took some ramp up
time um you know then in addition to
that we basically um you know provided
them full training like okay how do you
use canvas how would you use Discovery
if you're doing or we we had a you know
Granite State College set up an entire
training program they actually to able
to receive it had 12 different modules
that accumulated over time and they
could earn college I think I don't
remember exactly how many college
credits but they could earn college
credits towards a master's degree by
participating in these programs if they
wanted to learn those uh those kinds of
things so um and then throughout this
program time as well like we set an
entire um new website uh separate from
the department's website just about
covid response and it dealt there were
different sections of the website but
one of those sections had was simply
around uh pedagogy and how to do an
effective instruction um and and we had
you know Educators sharing on that
platform how they're doing it and what's
working and what's not working um so I
mean I I don't think I could do justice
to the amount of of touches and
resources um probably at least three
time well I know at least three times a
week through the spring uh we were doing
Statewide calls uh you know and
trainings um we were then in addition to
those three times a week state by calls
then that would spin off additional uh
lessons like okay what are you
struggling with and we would get on and
we would do Zoom meetings with them and
trying to explain to them how to resolve
certain problems or not um you know so
just trying to give them the tools um
and then the skills because again it was
a new paradigm for many of our Educators
uh to be able to be successful because
that was the goal to just make them as
efficas as
possible yes um do you have any data on
just kind of like the uptake of of all
the different programs and um yeah any
correlations with efficacy or or
anything like that I'm just looking for
data yes so we could go back I mean so
we could tell you how many people
started using Discovery how many people
are on canvas
and uh we could figure out I can you
know I can provide data to you and just
show you here's the engagements that we
have on these various platforms happy to
do
that represent
POA thank you for being here can I just
and I just want to but I want to caution
you know whether or not somebody use
Discovery or not is not going to be
indicative of the learning because if a
district already had their own resources
and they're doing a good job and that
teacher got everything they needing um
then they wouldn't have engaged it so it
wouldn't be as important um so just keep
that in in mind like if you had a low
uptake that's not necessarily indicative
of lack of efficacy um and again because
today I know that 100% of my schools are
using uh you know um Discovery there's
been like over 1.2 million engagements
on the Discovery platform um across the
state so um you know so if they didn't
grab it then they maybe subsequently
realized that it was um a valuable
resource but the the strategy was not
because we didn't have the ability to
drive them into a resource and force
them like we need to say like okay
everybody has if I had my way I would
have put my hand down and say
everybody's got to use canvas you know
everybody's got to use these curriculum
resources every one of your teachers has
to go through the udl training everybody
has to go through this but that's not
what it is what we did is we tried to
close gaps by making stuff available and
then Educators could engage or not
engage as they see fit okay thanks
that's helpful because yeah I'm hearing
all this I'm like I don't know that I
saw all of these that was all out there
you know like so but again and and we
communicated 100 ways a Sunday uh to be
able to make sure that everybody had
access to these things so we both
granted access and we tried to drive it
actually sorry can I ask one and and
just to be clear like all those were
available to families too right but the
difficulty is as you know by law like I
don't have families I can't contact
families right like I can I can pass
information to school leaders and then
School leaders are the ones who are
driving that message on to their
families so if I'm dropping it off at
the school and the school says like no
we don't need that and then maybe they
didn't share it with you then their
school leader believed that their
solution was going to be more efficac
than the resources we were providing
them I'm going to defer to represent po
off and if there's time because I know
the
Comm yes so
please so the sign shows that kids are
less affected by covid than uh uh Elders
uh
so what's understanding in Department
regarding to that low risk and how it
was communicated uh to the department
over time that maybe this group is not
the one that needs to be protected
because there's almost no risk for kids
for example no otherwise healthy kids
died from Co in New Hampshire yeah um so
again I I think I pointed to uh you know
Health as a covid-19 exit strategy is
one of the op-eds that I wrote um and I
do recognize that both
uh you know age but generally the age is
associated with the um the fact that
they tend not to have comorbidities
comorbidities um and so uh you know just
trying to
encourage um you know families that it's
going to be okay right so we were
working with again so C Health
Department Department of Health and
Human Services is communicating you know
that information we're trying to
communicate to families that we have a
plan to safely conduct school right you
can do do it we got this so that's what
our message all along has been we can do
this we can do it safely and it's okay
um but I will tell you that I had many
parents you know even up till the end
right calling me and and concerned or
like afraid I'm I'm not I don't I will
not send my child to that building
because I don't want them to get Co
right so the society had instilled a
fear in many families about an um you
know a danger that didn't exist to their
children um and so uh
you know they and and many adults
believed a lot of those fears as well
and so if those were repeated then that
just Amplified the the incorrect
information and you mentioned that uh
teachers unions were criticizing New
Hampshire approach in the Press but are
you aware that unions also had the
direct input on cdc's recommendations
regarding lockdowns and and other uh I I
do vagu recommend that there was a story
about that but that's you know what at
this point in time I would throw that
into the ancient history kind of a of a
thing but yes I do understand that that
may have been happening but again you
know we were you know Public Health was
taking that CDC guidance and translating
into a New Hampshire specific guidance
so uh rep uh commissioner I understand
that you have a hard stop I have a lot
of folks here that still have some
questions would you mind if people
funnel questions through me and then I
sent them to you and maybe you could get
back to us that way back back come back
oh that would be wonderful so thank you
so much for being
here this this will probably work on
getting scanned into our
site
um so thank you uh is there anyone from
the public wishing to speak to the
committee uh please approach introduce
yourself and tell us where you're from
and what you want to talk
about uh wait wait
just
so state your name where you're from
please turn your
mic okay my name is uh Joseph muroff
I've um lived in Keen for 10
years um I'm a uh I have no medical or
public health background except uh as I
when I started out I I was working as an
actuary on pension plans which have to
do with life
contingencies I have a uh a degree in
math from MIT undergraduate and an MBA
from Colombia in
finance
um okay where do I want to start uh I've
I've liked a lot of your questions
questions about trust and stuff like
that but
um these uh I'd like to go over these
sheets
and what I uh hope
to you hit your mic button so please
turn back on what I hope to prove to you
is that the um danger of covid was
severely
overstated and the danger of the
vaccine has not been recognized yet and
but it's very it's very dangerous okay
so
um let's go back
[Music]
to okay if we look at the Matrix in the
upper
left that is all the de this this comes
from New
Hampshire's um Health and Human Services
all this sta it's not them theirs
directly it's me summarizing what they
have collected so they're Co dashboard
correct Co they have a CO dashboard on
DH
yes I actually move along the graphs to
see when everything is at every time
okay so this in the upper left we have
the the first three years of covid I I
haven't collected the fourth year
because after May um the um the state of
emergency was over and it became much
more difficult to to collect data but
anyway so uh the the interesting thing
about that is if you look at the
percentages at the bottom you can see
that um ltcf is long-term care fa
facility and you can see the percentage
of the deaths that were in long-term
care facilities okay with 71% was the
first year but then then it it dropped
down uh
substantially okay so that's the uh and
and you get the totals over there now
the one in the middle shows the three
years the deaths by age for the three
years it
the in the first year which I call the
fear year um only
the in the
last the the vaccine started December
14th in New Hampshire so only at the
tail end of the first year could some
people get vaccines and the only people
who were allowed to to get them were the
Aged and the infirm the the at risk
population okay the
um the the second year
um the vaccines were rolled out in March
which began the second year of covid and
that's when The Wider population was
allowed to get it okay now I have
um I have several reasons to believe
that covid was the danger of covid was
overstated
the first the first one the earliest one
was CDC said at the end of uh 2020 that
only
6% of death certificates were covid
alone and out of the rest they had um an
average of 2.6
comorbidities so um that's an inference
that the people if covid is a rest
respiratory disease and like many
respiratory diseases there's an un
underlying condition that that tips them
over okay so that's the first thing the
second one is
um
in the keing Sentinel reported on
December
30th 2020 we had a um vaccine clinic
over at Keen Center which is in town
it's one it's a long-term care care
facility in
town and
um first of all in in TW in 2020 eight
people died in chesher County with covid
uh Ju Just eight
um so go go to
January and at Keen Center they had a
vaccine clinic on December 30th and the
keing sent reported that 12 people died
12 out of the 85 residents died in
January one month following their
vaccine clinic the month following their
vaccine clinic now
the New Hampshire said 10 of those 12
died with
covid okay and in total in total for
while eight died in 2020 in 10 months
was remember eight died out of 75,000
people in in uh cheser County and 10
died with covid at one facility with 85
people in one month following their
vaccine clinic so that that's a strong
inference okay here's here's um in total
for the year
2021 while less less than one died per
month in 2020 more than five died per
month in chesher
County um in 2021 with the with the
alleged benefit of the
vaccine okay um one more thing about
this
this this not
um the the less the less serious that
this is um Beth da Dr Beth daily um
at Governor sununu's April 29th
21 press conference was answering
questions at the end and one of the one
of the questions was um who's who's
dying from from this and this is what Dr
Daly
said Dr Del said I think the question
you want to know is about who the people
are in terms of age and medical
comorbidity all of the deaths now there
were 1300 more than 1300 dead at this
time with covid she
said all of the deaths except for one or
maybe two are either age 65 and older or
have underlying medical conditions so
there were only one or two people that
didn't have some other kind of
problem and we we also know that
um the the death definition of being
hospitalized with covid or dying with
covid was was very was loose in the
first year but then in January of the
second year both um both both Dr fouchi
and the World Health
Organization put out um a meta a memos
which foui said that there were too too
many positives we knew there were a lot
of false positives
we we knew we knew the public knew that
but and and um the World Health
Organization said why which was what you
know it's the number of Cycles you use
in the PCR test
so the fouchi said that there's too many
and the World Health Organization said
basically this test can be manipulated
which it was so the 2020 deaths were
over were less were less blamed on covid
were less um of were less true than the
than the deaths that came after this
makes the vaccine look more favorable
and covid look more
dangerous now okay now let's go let's go
to the numbers in in the middle graph in
the middle um table okay you can see
that at every age group every working
age group there's at least three times
as many dying with covid in the second
year in the Jabs year when these the
these are these are only people that are
not in long-term care facilities so
they're not in a nursing home and
they're not in
jail so this is this is our relatively a
relatively healthy population and in the
year that they can get the
Jabs um in every in at every age group
through more than three times for for
working people more than three times um
the number of people are dead now the
these are not huge numbers in New
Hampshire but project this out to um to
both the country and the world and you
you you you have a a huge problem okay
and some people could say some people
could say well maybe this is just
because the disease
spread but then you have um look to the
bottom line the bottom line is the
percentage who the percentage of deaths
that is less than age 70 so for the
first year for the 12 months
ending um in the first year only
12% were under were under age 70 but you
can see as as the vaccines kick in how
this how this um percentage goes up
until the for the second year the 12
months of the second year it's 37%
that's an extraordinary difference 12%
under ag7 or 37% under AG 70 well you
take a look like the the biggest CH the
biggest people hurt relatively is like
these these the 40y olds where seven
died in the first year and 49 in in the
second year now it should be remembered
that a
45-year-old has an expectation of Life
of 36 more years whereas an 85y old when
someone dies more than
80 um 85 year olds have have a future
expectation of about six years so it's
it's a much greater loss of life when
the young people are affected and that's
what actually has happened with with
these with these shots and then you see
you see it it hangs up there for a
little bit and then you know people stop
taking the shot
people knew you know and and now you see
it trailing down again okay and and and
and it's continued low I looked a little
bit in the fourth year it's continuing
down from that
20% okay so so
um that's this also notice on here um
the Z the 0er to9 group and the 10 to9
group now several of the people have
said that this is not a danger to young
people you can see we have and that's
there's only one death in in the uh even
till today from covid that is under age
20 so you got to you got to wonder a
little bit why um colleges insisted that
there are people it has to do with
spread also so it's it's it's not
clearcut it's like spread versus danger
and and you know what everybody has said
is right that it's not a danger to kids
but uh my wife is in uh is visiting her
grandson in Canada right now and she uh
she always comes back with a cold so
this idea of killing grandma is not
completely is not completely wrong in
other words the spread the the kids
they're on school buses they're whatever
you know there is something to that and
so you have to be
careful at the time when when this stuff
is around that um between the
association of uh of people like me who
are 72 and my grandchildren you know
this okay
um all
right so I I hope I hope I hope that
that shows that now um I've given you a
paper here and this just came out in the
last two weeks it's by this scientist uh
Toby um
Toby Roberts I think is and he um he's a
Toby Rogers and he's
uh he's he's about the best most clear
this is this is an easy read these these
10 pages this is probably the most ma
one of the most amazing things you have
ever read in in your life if you if you
read this and it
discusses what um we need to remake our
medical system okay it this discusses
what
um that this this is um you know I
wonder um I don't I don't know if it's
fair to ask you but um is it fair to ask
I don't want to do something that's
wrong um who's who's seen the movie
V only
one
really two okay I would I would
advise all I've seen vax and vax 2 vax
is better because it gets it's a
government movie also it's about
government it's it's much of what's in
that movie is like the game plan for CO
as far as CDC is concerned so it's it's
an extremely good movie for people who
who are in government to see and I I
would recommend that uh Mr um
mof is that correct I pronounce your
name correctly thank you um I just have
a quick question for you um you
mentioned earlier that the who in the
PCR test um and I believe the CDC and
they said the data could be
manipulated um is that information on
where you got that in this packet here
or do you have no um I I we've
been I'm I'm in a group and um we knew
and I checked with I we're in a group
and my one of the members of our group
wrote a letter I write a lot of letter
just to the editor I wrote I uh The
keing Sentinel accepts almost all of
them what they don't accept one of one
of the most important things I've ever
written was this is the reason these are
the reasons I will not take the vaccine
okay and I wrote that on April 3rd
2021 I sent it to a lot of print papers
nobody would print it I mean there was
all sorts of stuff coming out you know
pounding us to take the vaccine and
stuff stuff like this and there was no
one there was no one standing up and the
King Sentinel wouldn't print it now I'm
not I'm not I'm an independent I
supported Bernie in 2016 I supported
tulsy and yang in
2020 um I'm a Democrat right now but I
ran as a Republican for the legislature
last year I've rush for school board
I've run in four elections I've lost all
four of them in 10 years right I I won
one in thank you for trying what you
said thank you for putting your hat in
the ring right I was I won one in uh
Port Washington I got on the school
board through a fluke through a fluke
but that's uh anyway um there are a
number of industries that let us down uh
representative Penza has a question okay
and so does representative pull us
off so if you don't have those specific
areas about uh with PCR and running up
the Cycles I did ask uh in in what was
that our first committee meeting or
second committee meeting um that
information specifically from the
Department here in the state of New
Hampshire what we were at but I do have
that information to provide to the
committee because I think it's very
important um because at a at a period of
time when testing was very um you know
we didn't the testing now was totally
different when it first came out and so
and I knew that a like you're talking
about but I have specific scientific
information that talks about that
creator of the test and all of that so
I'd be happy to provide that to
committee because that's what you were
referring to when you were discussing
that right in regards with like false
positives and those numbers were
inflated yes they were
um more than half the positive for false
positives and it's also the case that
the diagnosis was I mean it could have
been that you had a positive P PCR test
28 days ago and then you go to the
hospital with something you've got the
heart disease you know and uh then you
die right you're hospitalized with covid
and you might not even have it you you
might not have had it because the PCR
test was false and you might not have it
because you got over it but you had it
the early EST it was that was that was
the worst case when did you have one
within the last month or but but the
um people people were using very high
numbers I say more than 50% because I
feel that safe I feel in 2020 okay now
in 2021 the the diagnoses were more
strict right and and and they looked it
was like antigen tests now and and they
were looking for other ways to confirm
it but that was when that was when the
vaccine was in gear okay right uh
representative poov has a question for
you sir thank you for being here and
thank you for giving us this important
uh uh data on New Hampshire des and uh I
mostly clear on the numbers the only one
uh you were mentioning about 12 people
dying 10 of them with Co and it was
after December 30th clinic but uh what
was population out of which uh 12 people
died was
those are those all people from that
clinic or are those people in the county
I all all people that were residents of
keen Center they were 85 people now but
also there was that was in The keing
Sentinel
um there was a
similar in U in um Peterboro there was
uh the Manan uh
reported a similar thing that that month
11 people died around the country if you
look if you look at the graphs of covid
deaths in the United States which are e
easy to find you go to the big
spreadsheet you click United States
you'll find that
that that um the week coincidentally
around January 6th that week was the
highest uh number of you'll see that's
where the the graph Peaks and it's
um you know after that it started going
down but that was the roll out the roll
out in the whole country was in this you
know in dece in late December and then
all these people died now it part of
that is going to be seasonal because
that's the season when people die from
respiratory disease it happens every
year it's usually flu
and this is
um but this but this that's that's the
ones that were labeled Co that's the
week that uh that it was the highest
uh uh just some clarification on these
uh numbers is this all of New Hampshire
or just ches County or just Kean no no
this is
the the example from Keen Center is
cheser County and Peterboro is not in
chesher County but th this sheet is all
this sheet is all of New Hampshire okay
for the three years thank you very
much what thank you for that
clarification okay does anybody else
have any
questions
no well good good luck to you all I I
hope you read that that paper because we
really um you know I I wanted if I was
asking Mr ad a question I would have
asked him what is the state policy with
regard to
um going to school and vaccines I mean
is this is this a maybe some of you know
I I didn't live here I would hate to be
a parent right now knowing what I know I
would hate to be a parent and having
having to make that decision but then
read read that paper I gave you and uh
representa beler I was just going to
offer an answer to that um we do not as
of now nor has New Hampshire ever uh
added the covid vaccine to the childhood
schedule to require it for any of our
Public Schools so it's not something
that has to happen what about the other
vaccines the other vaccines there were
there are quite a few that are part of
uh we're we we're a special committee
specifically on covid so uh we're not
going to get into anything other
vaccines um and i' just like to say
thank you so much for coming putting
this data together and uh if you have
any questions reach out to reach out to
us and uh we'll see if we can get you
some answers and my phone number and
email are on the graph so I see that you
you can ask me questions too so thank
you so much I appreciate it and I
appreciate your
patience um is there any other business
before the committee uh representative
Belcher yes it would be all right I just
like to um read into the record not in
totality just by typing
um various um documents that have not so
much to today but to our previous things
that speak to things that I'd like to
enter into the record that'd be all
right please do so thank you just take
give me a minute or two here so we've
got um press release New Hampshire ghhs
uh regarding covid-19 vaccine
eligibility to children as young as six
months we have um abstract of uh a study
intracellular reverse transcription
fiser bio Tech covid-19 mRNA vaccine in
vitro in human liver cell
lines uh column by Michael Graham
probellum politicians struggle to
explain pandemic protest hypocrisy from
2020 we have PC uh
column uh PCR test is flimsy says
inventor and
Court uh we have column Betsy McHugh uh
if you're the wrong race the P the push
for healthc care Equity could kill you
we have column New Hampshire Journal New
Hampshire using race-based Equity metric
and distribution of early doses of
covid-19 vaccine we have a long study um
of M this is a big one the the nature uh
publication of ribosomal frame shifting
resulting from the MRNA
vaccination we have the press release by
the Missouri attorney
general um social media censorship
regarding covid we have another press
release DHHS IM immunization guidance
for parents we
have a large study um igg4 antibodies
induced by repeated
vaccination um with the MRNA uh
technology we have uh uh press release
uh from Florida Florida State Surgeon
General calls for halt in the use of
covid-19 R RM mRNA vaccines we
have uh a column uh CMS Center for
Medicaid uh studies I believe it is adds
20% to inpatient medicare payment for
covid-19 patients we have uh FEMA press
release FEMA to help pay funeral costs
for covid-19 related deaths we have from
the sage
Journal
um uh Adverse Events for mRNA vaccines
have uh exceeded um signal thresholds
for myocarditis and other conditions we
have New Hampshire DHHS Health alert um
regarding vaccines for inference and
children we have covid-19 drug makers
pressured Twitter to censor activists
pushing for generic vaccine from The
Intercept we have another study covid-19
two- rare vaccine side effects detected
in large Global study we have uh an
article study covid-19 vaccination
strongly associated with severe adverse
safety signal in mild carditis we have a
study behavioral nudges increase
covid-19
vaccinations we have
a house press release uh Bishop demands
FDA resend its unconstitutional
race-based monocolonal antibody
allocations we have a uh in-depth New
Hampshire article State House protesters
want stay-at-home order lifted along
with an image from that article from
outside this state house we have another
article New Hampshire extended
stay-at-home order what has changed I'm
sorry this is a oh no this is an article
NPR uh we have from uh a a social media
image from the uh State of New Hampshire
stay atome
order we have uh us hospital is getting
paid more to label cause of death as
Corona
virus um which I will say on here
actually there was an error that was
noted in the headline that is corrected
in the body of the text it was not they
were not paid more to label cause of
death as Corona virus they were paid
more to treat covid-19 patients than
other patients we have a study uh I'm
sorry this is not a study a um article
will nudge Theory survive the
pandemic um State propaganda can
flourish in times of Crisis we have
article vaccine makers funneled
undisclosed campaign cash to Democrats
and Republicans in 2020 from The
Intercept we have article the Twitter
fals big farmer pressured platform to
censor covid-19 vaccine
debate we have the transcript of a
recent um interview between tuck Carlson
and Brett Weinstein that is directly
related to all of this Co info we're
looking
at uh we have the White House covid-19
censorship uh machine article from the
new civil liberties Alliance and we have
finally political Politico article
suddenly Public Health officials say
social justice matters more than social
distance
uh from
2020 thank you and I will provide these
electronically so we don't have to scan
all of them as well thank you
representative Belcher is there any
other business uh representative Evel
thank you very much um I was just sort
of I I wanted to just take a couple of
minutes maybe we could uh I just wanted
to ask the chair what she had in mind
for um I know we have the homeland
security director coming in on the 29th
and I wondered who was at 9:00 a.m. umgg
so far I haven't uh that is as far as
I've got although I listening today I
think Dr Chan would be somebody that we
would want to have here and talk with um
because I think that would be important
is there anybody else um I know that
we'll probably have more questions for
the commission commissioner edel BL at
sometime and I'm sure we'll have uh more
questions for commissioner Tilly at some
point but I think having uh uh the
director from Homeland Security here uh
will probably open up a a new amount of
um curiosity and uh questions for us uh
which is the 29th um and at this time I
don't have anyone else speaking that day
I am going to look to I have people
contact me that do want to come in so I
will be checking availability but as you
know um we are subject to like if we
want Dr Chan here we are subject to his
schedule um so I've been trying to to
work uh to limit us like to every other
week but if we have to do back I'm
beholden to their schedules so
unfortunately I can't tell you exactly
when we'll be meeting after the 29th are
you shooting for Fridays FKS I am still
hoping for Fridays I think Friday seems
to work best for most
people um
is there anyone you have in mind uh that
you'd like to see in representative
evil um I I had mentioned Dr Chan um one
person I mean I I don't know how
relevant it is I could check in with him
is the is the head of doit he's the IT
director and I don't know how much he
had involved with the with the remote
and and just getting things going I
could ask him that's just one idea but I
think you're right when the homeland
security um fellow director comes maybe
he'll give us some ideas we can spawn
off of him but I um and you know I I
don't know maybe we want someone from
the governor's office at some point to
come and speak but I I think you've hit
the the high points um the only other
thing I would say is that the 29th is
Easter weekend so maybe not the
afternoon if we could avoid it okay I
will take that under advice advisement
okay uh represent likeus you had
something oh yeah I was just trying to
make sure we deal with that stack of
paper and then whoever that's supposed
to go okay so so that that was uh
something that was given last week but
it was a bunch of all papers so uh the
researcher put them all together in nice
neat little packets for us they were the
executive orders that were printed out
and Madam chair on the March 29th I will
not be here that is a religious
holiday oh it is good I didn't even
realize that when I scheduled it and it
was the only day that the director said
he could be here so I
apologize I get it trust me I'm sorry so
yeah absolutely not in the afternoon so
maybe we'll try and make it short and
make it just till 11 o'clock or
something or 11:30 so we can okay so we
won't uh if it's okay with the committee
I will not try and get anyone else but
director buckton here on that Friday
does that
work the full day for me is out I
understand but I'm just trying to I'm
glad you brought it to my attention and
I'm just trying to be cognizant of
everybody else okay uh if is there
anything
else if not I'd say we're adjourned yeah
thank you thank you we link for
our
for